okay good morning everyone and welcome
to this meeting of development control
committee a mid-suffolk district council
can I first of all just remind everyone
some of the domestic Arrangements uh can
I ask that you ensure that microphones
are turned off when not in use please do
not interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interact we will ask you to leave please
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
or Switched Off and can you also do the
same with your laptops just to make sure
they don't ping every time an email
comes in
um we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
could members make sure they're logged
on and ready to use the app
um I would like to remind everyone
present this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewings the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to consent it to being recorded and by
entering this meeting as the speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public May
film record photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded you do hear the
fire alarm today please leave the
building immediately by the fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
at Ipswich Town Football Club please
follow the science to the fire exits at
the end of each floor and do not enter
the atrium the ground floor walkway
areas
if you're in the atrium at the time of
the alarm please follow the size of the
nearest fire exit do not use the stairs
or the lifts that's why I use the stairs
and not the lifts
do not enter the bill do not enter the
building told you it's safe to do so
okay so welcome everyone and just for
the benefit of those that may not have
been to a planning meeting before
um I'm Matthew Hicks one of the uh one
of my with along with my colleagues here
on my left the district councils will
make a decision on the applications
before us today the mid-suffolk district
council a ward member may speak on an
application in their Ward but may not
vote which is why councilman is sitting
on the other side of the chamber for
this item
in the room we have the chief planning
Office of Philip Isbell the area
planning manager Gemma Walker Ian to
press our legal advisors and then we'll
have the case officers coming through
for each item Bradley heifer Jasmine
wired and Helen Noble we have other
officers here who will help and come in
as as relevant during each application
including the sustainable travel officer
someone from SCC and transport planning
and we have governance officers as well
so that will keep us hopefully all
taking you along smoothly so if we go
straight to the agenda apologies for
absence do we have any please
thank you chair we have apologies from
councilor Passmore and councilor Mueller
is substituting
thank you very much do we need to
receive any decorations of disclosable
pecuniary interests or other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members we'll start off at
the background yeah custom there
um Mr Bailey here items B and C on the
agenda is known to me Liz in my ward
I'm a elmsworth parish counselor an
amsil pouch council is the uh is related
to the fourth item on the agenda
you do then would be to speak on it and
leave the room
probably the best thing that's what we
would normally do someone has an
interest yeah so thank you yep coming
along the front yes cancel
uh yes I unusually
um
at the time that the the parish council
in Elms World decided to um to to try
and um
get keep this piece of land free of
building
um I was actually in Elmsford Parish
councilor so I bring knowledge of the
decisions at the time I don't think I'd
bring any any current interest
working yeah
a good morning chairman ladies and
gentlemen our councilor Matheson did
take my advice on this this morning and
it's there's clearly some difference in
time and a decision by the parish
council than to acquire the land and
application for planning permission now
are separated I don't think it's
properly right to declare it so I don't
think it's there's any disqualification
arises okay councilor field
my new issue I think but uh uh I can see
shrublins and barn church out of the
back of my house just about
probably could see this development
when or if it gets built okay thank you
for that and cancer Humphries
Mr thank you I'm A Stone Market Town
councilor and part of the planning
committee this is raised on Wednesday's
planning meeting I abstain from that
vote so I'd come in here uh without
determination
thank you very much okay
yes councilman sorry yes I'm also a
member of Stone Market Town Council
planning committee and I also abstained
on the vote last Wednesday when it was
her thank you
right thank you very much
um
okay we'll move on to decorations of
personal site visits any that needs to
be declared
sorry
oh I've never said that it's all right
decorations of lobbying we've all had
the probably the same letter from Taylor
wimpy
okay thank you thank you sorry and then
decoration is a personal site visitors
yes councilman yeah I visited site 70
okay thank you
okay next we need confirmation the
minutes the meeting held on the 12th of
October are there any points of uh note
anything you want to raise in the
minutes that need
changing okay so can I have a proposal
please to propose the minutes yes
councilman the second day thank you
okay
so we have a proposer and a second
Wisconsin e-burn proposed Wisconsin
thank you Chad that vote is now in
progress members
thank you chair councilman Muller I
noticed your receivers over there will
you be
um I will abstain so I wasn't at that
meeting thank you very much in that case
share that six votes four and two
abstentions thank you thanks very much
okay so the minutes the meeting have now
been confirmed I will sign up after the
meeting okay uh and do we need to
receive any notifications for petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
today we have received a valid petition
objecting to application number DC
2203423 which is the elmswell
application the petition has 39 valid
signatures and no rejected signatures
do we need to do anything on the back of
that or we just note it for noting okay
thank you very much
okay next item is we move on to the
schedule of planning application so we
will keep to the order as in the papers
first item is 7A the land Northwest of
Stow up and Road Stone Market are now
ask the case on Sir Bradley heifer to
take the item through and introduce it
to committee
foreign
good morning members ladies and
gentlemen
um this first item you're being asked to
consider is an application for fall
planning permission for a residential
development of 258 dwellings on a site
Northwest of Stow Upland Road in Stone
Market
you'll remember this was last reported
to committee on the 29th of September
September
and was deferred at that meeting members
requesting some additional information
and as I go through the presentation
hopefully um points that have been
raised will be addressed
this is a slide showing The Wider area
of the and the location of the site the
point the elements I point out on this
particular drawing are
the um
the site itself of course you've got
it's on the periphery of the the town
Stow Market you've got the Trunk Road
the A14 running through to the top of
the site and also elmswell to the
Northeast
sorry let's just start Upland to the
Northeast apologies
this is a larger scale aerial plan and
this shows again the location you'll see
next door some vacant land which was the
site known as Ash's Farm which was also
discussed at the meeting on the 29th
so they're actually abutting each other
um
again you can see the line of the the
A14 which bounds the site to the north
a further
larger scale aerial shop again the the
one that the thing that you'll note from
this is a white patch on that particular
drawing which is the disused chicken
sheds which are occupying part of the
site at the moment
and this is the red line application
site which accompanies
the application
you may recall at the last meeting there
was some discussion in relation to the
means of access to the site and again it
was pointed out at the meeting that the
ownership
extends up to that point there
and I'll talk further about where the
highway land extends as well because
we've had now had confirmation from the
applicant that's the extent of the
highway land in relation to the
roundabout
and that plan also shows the chicken
sheds in greater
straight to detail
this is the constraints map in terms of
the constraints
so you've got the footpath was not
constraint but as such but it's marked
on there's the footpath that runs
through both ashy's farm and diapers
farm and you'll notice the line of the
built up area boundary of Stone Market
and also just across the edge there on
the on the slide Stow Upland and the
line of the the trunk road again which
which is a constraint that has to be
acknowledged as part of the development
when you build obviously anywhere near a
trunk Road and the other elements that
have been pointed out on this plan are
listed buildings which are within the
vicinity of the site
this plan is taken from a development
brief which was produced on behalf of
the council following the adoption of
The Stone Market area action plan and it
helpfully identifies
the two areas that we've been talking
about previously in today Zone one
comprises Ashley's Farm which has
already been discussed discussed by
committee today we're looking at zones
two and Zone zones two and three
um
and the
division of the two sites is virtually
identical to the plan that you see there
which again is helpful
this is taken from the development brief
again it's the the concept plan which
accompanies the the planning application
sorry concept plan that's in the
development brief
um
you probably will struggle to read this
on the slide but the areas that are
colored this color the salmon color are
or suggested for more dense development
denser development
less dense development boundary
and strategic areas of open space
and this plan is the previous iteration
previous version of the layout plan
which you saw which has been shown at
the last committee meeting this has been
adjusted slightly following the
um
the the foul of the the meat of the
application at that meeting but it shows
the general arrangement of the
development in as an interpretation of
the concept plan
that was in the development brief so in
other words you have areas of
built form density is not necessarily
higher in one area than another but you
have areas of perimeter block density
you have an area of open space through
the center which again is an
interpretation of that and areas towards
the bottom other things to point out on
that plan are the the Link Road through
which joins star Upland Road through to
the ashes Farm site and
area in the corner here which following
the deferral which is the apartment
blocks following the deferral there's
been an adjustment to how that works
which I'll explain in due course
this plan does actually show the latest
iteration of the the
um the proposals in terms of what I can
point out at this scale um
one of the issues that was looked at
last time was the provision of triple
parking
in this particular case there are
instances of triple parking as has been
said in the the report
and as a way of addressing that the
applicant has
provided additional visitor spaces
along which you can just about see on
this plan here along the areas adjacent
to the triple parking so we've got
instances of triple parking there's
additional visits and spaces provided
and two plots on the site have actually
had the triple parking removed through
changes to the the dwelling type
this plan you have seen before which
again is an early iteration but the
general arrangement of the affordable
housing across the site hasn't changed
the 35 requirement is achieved on the
site and our strategic housing team are
content with the mix and also the
location of the units their distribution
this is a broader plan or of the
accesses various accesses onto the um
Stow Upland Road which are being
considered as part of this planning
application
um if I zoom in slightly I'll talk
through each of these I've got a larger
scale drawing of the access but one
important change that has occurred since
it came to committee last time is the
provision of the cycleway footway link
here
that wasn't proposed previously
I think you'll recall that a lot of the
cycling Footwear movements were either
concentrated at the new access or
utilizing the um the route through which
is to the south of the site which again
you'll see photographs of those fairly
soon so that that is a new element there
was discussion at the previous planning
committee about
this particular element which was the
access for pedestrians and cyclists
across the new
vehicular access into the site and and
what's happened is that the um the
Refuge in the middle has been made wider
so that's not so narrow as it was before
and as a consequence there's more time
for people or more people to wait at
this point in order to cross should
track as and when traffic allow
including cyclists so that is seen as a
an improvement in regard to how that
Junction works for cyclists and
pedestrians the other thing that's
pertinent to this is the toucan Crossing
that hasn't changed the location of that
because of one of the queries at last
committee was whether that is in the
right position and we've had
confirmation from the applicant's own
highways consultants and also the
highway Authority that they are content
with the location of that particular
crossing the last thing I should point
out on this drawing is it's also
proposed now to widen the cycleway and
footway provision
up to its point near the mall
Junction
and down to this point here just past
the um past the tuping crossing so that
would be a widening of that provision
there in order to now allow more room
for pedestrians and cyclists
um I think that's a two meter width at
the moment it's proposed to or it might
be three but it's gone up to 3.5 because
that's all taking place in the highway
the dotted line there you can see is the
extent of the highway and that's that's
helpfully flagged up
um this plan you have seen before which
is connectivity plan on the site itself
the main change here
is that that access is now being
provided
cyclists and pedestrians at this point
and that will enable
a movement across the north of the site
for cyclists and pedestrians rather than
having to go southwards towards the town
this is the wider connectivity plan
which includes the ashes Farm site which
I mentioned earlier which again
is a tricky situation bearing in mind
this is a full application and and the
um the proposal on the The Ashley's Farm
site is an outline application but
notwithstanding that
both parties have been talking to each
other and produces connectivity plan
which
um thinks about how how people will move
across the site generally in terms of
cars
and more importantly pedestrians and
cyclists
and you'll note from that that the root
of the footpath
is actually shown through there which
will be utilized as part of this
um this plan you haven't seen before but
we thought is useful in order to to give
you an impression of what happens in The
Wider Network bearing in mind the site
we're talking about
is up in this corner that small blue
stub you see there is the new cycle
point and as you'll see from the key
there the blue lines are off-road
cycleways so because of the existing and
we did discuss this previously because
of the existing infrastructure around
this area and as has been qualified by
the highway Authority there is limited
space
to enable off-site or sorry off-road
cycle provision to be created but there
is a network albeit that it does take a
slightly circuitous route to the center
which can be utilized and that this
could this scheme could tap into
um these you've seen before these are
the Street Scenes I won't spend too much
time on this particular element save to
say that the Topography of the site is
something that is a challenge for Anyone
Who develops and you'll note from the
the
um the plan that it does vary depending
on where the where you see these blue
lines which are taken on an approximate
north south and east west
orientation
these are the general plans of the
houses which I'll go through fairly
quickly they use a range of traditional
materials that you'd expect to find in
this location and use traditional built
forms
similar to other dwellings in the area
so in terms of context we were content
that this
meets the context that it would need to
relate to
um if I quickly go towards
this is the original apartment block and
you'll recall from the um the plan I
showed a while ago that it's in a
prominent location it's the only
three-story building
um the post for the development and it's
in the top northeast corner so its
prominence will be something that will
be evident um
development
as part of the discussions with the
developer we've reorganized the design
of this and there's two reasons for that
one to make it more responsive as a
design in itself and you'll see in
in particular
what we've achieved as a design feature
is what's called rustication was
basically making render look like Stone
so you've got stone with bricks sitting
on top of it which is construction as a
construction makes more sense than Stone
sitting on tin of a frame sorry bricks
sitting on timber frame the projections
here have been made stronger to break up
that elevation
but a key element
of the design revision if I go to this
plan it's probably better is that this
predict this projection now comes
towards this way away from the A14
whereas previously it was doing that
so it's taking accommodation away from
the A14 which I think bearing in mind
comments that were made at the previous
uh committee
um it is a positive response as far as
we're concerned and it's seeking to
address that issue notwithstanding of
course that the location is unaltered
the design itself is amended and another
thing to bear in mind is that the
applicant does
control the land up to the red line so
therefore in terms of a soft Landscaping
approach this is something that can
obviously be addressed through that
mechanism
another issue that came out the last
committee was the amenity of the units
to the north northern boundary the ones
that are immediately adjacent to the
trunk road we've got a section here
which shows the carriageway of the A14
and the associated slope leading up to
where the bat where the site begins so
all of that is the Trunk Road area up to
that point this is the acoustic fence
which is required as part of the
development to attenuate noise there'll
be Landscaping in front of that
uh and this is a position of a typical
unit facing the A14
in terms of Outlook which I think was
one of the concerns
um
the way that this works at first floor
level and the intervening distance with
the the boundary treatment here
views are
ostentably across into to the land to
the north rather than views directly
into the Trunk Road itself and we're
satisfied that that
doesn't create a situation where
amenities overly impacted or visual
amenities overly impacted purely by
location in terms of the amenity of
putting dwellings there in Principle
as that is a frontage as part of a
development in planning terms we would
prefer to see
a public Frontage to that development
rather than a private Frontage that's
two functions because basically with a
public Frontage you've got houses
fighting on to the the public space
which is basically the A14 Trunk Road
and by having houses in this position
what you actually create is a situation
that where the um the amenity space
behind those houses is screened
by the building itself which assists in
attenuation of of disturbance whereas if
that was handed there is a potential of
course that you'd have the houses there
say and then you'd have private amenity
areas directly adjacent to that space
so we think there are benefits of um of
arranging the site in those terms both
spatially and in terms of amenity
um unfortunately I couldn't get the
second
um plan into your pack early enough but
this is another plan which shows the
height of the three-story unit in the
corner in relation to
the adjacent round
which are the two carriageways the
roundabout you can see there
and also the existing dwelling or the
existing building on the other side
so that will give you an idea and again
it will not not understand the fact that
it's a three-story unit the the land
drop itself does we feel make this more
manageable as an element in itself just
as a built form element bearing in mind
it is the only three-story building on
there
um quickly run through the photographs
which are unchanged from the last uh
presentation which is the approach from
Star Upland just before we get to the
bridge uh before we get to the
roundabout
and then views of the roundabout itself
and you can see just see the the site
appearing on the right hand side here
again that's coming off the roundabout
these are all taken off of Google Earth
or street view because um purely for
convenience not being wanted to stand in
the carriageway unfortunately
um there's some views across the site
again these will give you some idea
hopefully of the um the expanse of
agricultural land which is on a is on a
bit of a slope across which is um one of
the constraints that has got to be dealt
with that's a view of the houses on the
other side of the road which are between
planted areas and I I think that this is
the approach that we feel could be
respected on this side as well
that's a view down the road itself
and these are points of access so where
there's a gap in the Hedge it's it's
looking to take accesses in there rather
than trying to take out lots of trees
unnecessarily in fact one of the key
elements of this is looking to retain
the the tree and hedge boundary
treatment that's on the site as an
amenity Resource as part of the
development
that's a distance view of the Redundant
chicken sheds again that's the point
approximately in the street and it's
hard to get context I accept but where
the main axis would be coming in
and the point you can see
here is the island which would be
replaced the existing Island which would
be replaced by the the toucan Crossing
these are views going down towards the
town
again I mentioned the access
through for the footpath which exists at
the moment and this is taken off Stow
Upland Road
and serves dwellings as you can see and
also provided a route to the Redundant
chicken sheds
so
that takes you virtually up to the
chicken shed site but that all contains
a public right away which will be
retained as part of the development
that's the end of the presentation but I
think just quickly I will um draw your
attention to several items that are on
the um table papers
at the time my report was written we had
received comments from the highway
Authority and the sustainable travel
officer and also Play services landscape
which are included in the bundle that
was a part of the original
package you've received subsequently we
did see we did receive a comment from
stowmarket Town Council which you can
see the first line there the Town
Council reiterates its strong objections
to this application and then goes on to
identify what they are so there's a
sustained objection from the Town
Council
the sustainability officer was able to
provide a comment in relation to
sustainable energy issues which is
included on the table papers
and the key
reference in there is the third
paragraph where the officer says I need
to know how the properties are to be
heated
subsequent to that and apologies that
we've had
time constraints we did receive a
further response from the officer
following clarification from the
applicants we've received that 11
minutes past five yesterday
but with your agreement chair can I read
that out now
um so this is
um just to qualify this is the current
comment of the sustainability officer
I have reviewed the applicants recently
published response on sustainability and
energy and I note the contents they're
in
I have also just been provided with a
letter from the sustainability
Consultants AES dated 14th of October
2022.
it seems that the choice of heating
system and the subsequent CO2 emissions
for various parts of the site are
assessed on calculations on the old
building regulation part L 2013 which
uses the standard assessment procedure
sap 2012 and part L 2021 which uses sap
10.2
sap 2012 as the date suggests is 10
years old and whilst it has had periodic
upgrades it still uses CO2 emissions
emission figures for various fuels that
are several years old
this means that sap 2012 overestimates
the CO2 emissions for any fixed
buildings EG air source heat pumps that
use electricity
there are other inaccuracies that have
been corrected in the newer sap-10
sap 10 2 uses up-to-date CO2 emissions
data for electricity that take into
account The Greening of the National
Grid in region in recent years
an ashp in a dwelling built to the part
L 2021 sap 10 2 standard should use
slightly less electricity to achieve the
same Comfort levels because of the
improved fabric performance requirements
compared to the same unit built to part
L 2013 slash sap 2012.
the amount of electricity used will not
be substantially different but the CO2
emissions will be significantly lower
under part L 2021 sap 10.2
CO2 emissions for gas appliances and
Electrical Supply appliances under sap
2012 are different but for sap 10.2 are
nearly the same
by mixing the standards and different
fuels used on heating on various parts
of the site it is difficult to determine
the optimum Arrangement when just
considering just the statements in the
response and letters referring to
estimates of CO2 reduction
I would suggest that the full sap
calculations under each standard for all
the various permutations of heating
Appliance and provision of fault
photovoltaic PV panels are provided so
that absolute numbers relating to the
CO2 emissions can be compared only after
that stage will I have sufficient
information to be able to respond
apologies for the length of that chair
members but I think it's important that
you you're aware of that
so we have had a latest response and I
appreciate that's a lot to take in but
um
you you're fully up to date with that
particular point
um if I just quickly write in uh run
through the other
elements on the table papers you'll see
that we've had an environmental health
noise odor officer common which you've
hopefully been able to read which is
suggesting that in order that we don't
face a position where uh air source heat
pumps are installed at a later date
and these may require acoustic
assessment
it suggested that we should withdraw PD
for that particular element
I've made no particular comment on that
but I think it's important that you're
aware of the comment that's been made
um and at the time we produced this
report uh this table papers we haven't
had a comment back from the parish
council star Upland or Stone Market
Society
and just very quickly additional updates
you
'll have hopefully had a chance to look
at the drawing or the plan on the last
page page five of the um the table
papers which basically gives you
um shows you where the extent of the
highway bound
Shang green along the whole of that
section of Stow Upland Road so again you
can see that if you can recall the red
line plan I showed earlier there will be
landing between that and the highway
land
which isn't under the ownership of the
applicant
and very very lastly final point
in the report there's a list of elements
that we would seek to secure through
section 106 we double counted the um the
requirement for a 10 000 pound
contribution towards a traffic
regulation order that appears twice is
in the it's listed as a 10 000
contribution and then is also listed in
more detail at the end
so I think you've heard enough from me
and I'll leave it there too thanks very
much can I just check on a couple of
things then just some 100 sure then
obviously other questions so
obviously in our papers on page 31 uh we
have the reasons that this committee
asked the applicant to go away and to
consider uh the request to the committee
and then to come back
so in terms of design of the three-story
proposed unit
that's still in the same location
uh but so the location hasn't changed
is that correct that's correct yes okay
in terms of the parking removal of
triple parking there is still triple
parking
there is still triple parking but I
guess yeah in terms of going all air
source heat pumps and removing gas that
hasn't happened
no okay okay thank you
right happy just I just wanted to be
clear what it has or has not happened
yes we'll start down the end to cancer
Mathison yes thank you Jay yeah I did
want to um go first because uh I need to
point out that of course I was away at
the September meeting
um and so I am starting at some
disadvantage compared to to other
members in asking questions and um so I
may all right let's just ask the
question yeah well I made therefore ask
quite a few questions that you've had
the answers so if you have three to
start with and then yeah I think the
first one I've got was can you clarify
that whether the the the design brief
um was adopted because it's somewhere in
the papers it says it wasn't adopted and
somewhere else it says it was adopted so
um I just want to clarify that one first
and
um
the second one is
I'm gonna get there
um yes the crowdfather there aren't any
Bungalows either
no there are no Bungalows that's right
and
to get through here
um
sorry about this
yeah yeah I'll be happy to hear from
others okay
let's answer those questions first
Bradley then we'll move on to other
members um well just on the first point
I'm checking as we speak because I want
to be absolutely clear what state is of
that
um
the document is and I'll just say we
confirm there are no Bungalows proposed
but if you bear with me and I'll come
back to that point if that's okay
Council Phil did you want to have any
questions
yeah something I did
um
there are a few issues one of them
really the um
the relationship to the design brief the
the this uh a comment which says
it's conceptually possible to interpret
the
number of houses a number of dwellings
on this site as being compliant with the
design brief it doesn't say it's it is
compliant it says it's conceptually
possible to read the figures in a
favorable way or to understand that a
little bit more and really the point is
is the density which seems to be from
the numbers quite high is the density on
this uh compare compatible with the
design brief or is it much higher in
this particular element perhaps compared
with with the total area the design
proof covered so that was one issue
the second issue really is the
roundabout access that we've just been
looking at the the area on my highways
I'm somewhat concerned that there
obviously wasn't an intention and a
belief that to access at that point
would be superior
and we can't achieve that there's two
comments one of them says it's in in
separate ownership but there's a narrow
a ransom strip in separate of ownership
another point that claims that there is
a covenant that prevents connection
wondered on the validity of that surely
covenants can be changed by a court of
law
so that's point two the second one
really or third one really is about heat
pumps and solar panels I think it might
be better to come back to that because
it can be quite an extensive
discussion do you want to come back on
those Bradley
the risk of us all trying to answer the
same question chairman
um so the land adjacent they're taking
in reversal of a land address into the
roundabout there's a strip of Highway
land but the application Society
it's more of a rectangular shape so
there is a parcel of land which isn't
owned or at least which we don't have
certainty about it's it's proposed use
because it's not part of this
application
um because it's not part of this
application and there may be around
I wrecked about a few future of that and
been discussing that with public realm
so at the moment that's an ongoing
conversation it's not part of the
planning application before you and I
think the design brief itself might
acknowledge that there would be no
access onto that roundabout now the
reasons behind that yes it's true you
can change a covenant usually that
involves the Covenant holder accepting a
degree of money in order for that to
happen in the usual way so relaxing and
releasing covenants is not done without
agreement which
um is not part of what's before us today
and you know I always say decide the
application in front of you the access
onto the roundabout idea is not part of
the design brief so for
active I think there's a side
conversation about that land around the
roundabouts some of it is Highway land I
think some of it and Crest may be able
to speak to this themselves in more
detail as to what they understand of the
legal position I'm certainly exploring
whether that has a future because I
don't wish to see that become an awful
piece of land but is that a starter on
that point uh Council field
the issue really is are we
modifying what highways believe will be
necessary for a safety point of view
because of an ownership issue a minor
ownership issue
not and you're telling me that the
design brief which is this is supposed
to follow did not incorporate access to
that okay I understand that I think
uh yeah so I'll let Mr Chester correct
me when I get it wrong and what the
highways Authority will or won't accept
but
um the uh the point of access onto the
roundabout was not I thought considered
to be peripheral or or alternative I
don't think that's actually been in
conversation for some considerable time
it doesn't sit within the development
brief as as the access point that's
expected
um and I wouldn't describe releasing a
covenant as a minor matter because
clearly persons with an interest in
covenants can expect substantial
negotiation around their release so
I don't know if that answers the
question in any way shape or form okay
Council Humphries here next
okay Mr chair just one question Bradley
the noise abatement fence that's on the
Northern edge of the development site is
that the whole length of that
development site or not
the requirement would carry across for
um diapers and the ashes or the site
we're talking about now and Ashes as
well yeah
fun
character thanks Bradley for the
presentation
um I've just got a couple of questions
um presumably if the site is going to be
half gas half s or seat pump they'll
have to put gas infrastructure in
through the whole side
and at whatever cost that would be
um secondly
um could you just confirm that the
construction management plan will
include
um
some recourse for the safety of
pedestrians and cycle cyclists along a
very busy stretch along Stow Upland Road
and some means of not being
avoiding hcv type of trucks
um thanks and thirdly on the proposed
bus route that IFC that will be in the
section 106.
um will there be a timing attached to
that because if this site starts
before the Ash's Farm site
will let will there be a kind of cut-off
point at which that bus route will then
start rather than it wait for both sides
to be complete thank you
thank you Council um in regard to first
point um
at this stage the information we have is
that gas
boilers will be in will be installed as
part of the development until such time
there is a change in the relevant
requirements of the the building
regulations that's my understanding of
the situation we have the developer here
maybe to to clarify that
um the construction management plan
there is an element specifically in the
traffic
assessment which advises about Banks men
during school times and and times when
that that route's used by cyclists and
pedestrians quite heavily but that's if
it hasn't been picked up in the um
in the report as a specific requirement
we could certainly add that I don't
think that would be anything that would
be seen as designer
and with regard to timing
um the way that the the contribution
would work I think that that would be
um sorry for the bus route that would
that would be something that the Suffolk
County Council uh travel people who
provide the service or would be using
the money to provide the surface would
be able to advise on in terms of when
that might actually happen because as I
understand it has to be a critical mass
in order create a new service and when
that comes is is probably something that
they'll be able to provide more
information on unfortunately
uh thank you one of my questions I've
found the answer to by looking at a a
detailed drawing
um you mentioned in your report Bradley
that that there was a desire or or
ambition to maintain all as much of the
tree and hedging boundary of the site as
possible is that actually conditioned or
is that part of the landscape strategy
and how can we be assured that they're
not going to
chop down more of the existing hedging
than they really really need to as has
happened in other applications thank you
the extent of tree and hedge removal is
identified in the arboricultural impact
assessment
our tree officer is considered that and
he's content with the amount of tree
loss and the importantly the the types
of tree that are being removed in in
other words their status can three up to
one so I think that the number of trees
and the types of trees that are being
removed is accepted and he's also
requested that the
development take place in accordance
with that submitted of cultural impact
assessment so as far as we're concerned
there isn't a proper assessment of all
the trees on the site that are going to
be removed which we could control
adequately unless they wanted develop
only to change it in which case I'd need
to amend their proposals and we're going
through the whole process again well on
that particular element
okay I'm going to go back to Philipp is
spell and thank you chairman yes I think
councilman asked about the status of the
design brief which
um In fairness is helpfully a slightly
ambiguous on our website
um so the design brief is listed as an
adopted document together with all of
the other allocation
um design briefs and master plans for
Stone Market
um it doesn't appear from what I see on
the website that it has actually been
through an adoption as an SPD process
um it was produced in discussion and
dialogue with the two site landowners so
they are from my perspective cited on it
but I don't think it's followed the
formality to be adopted as such and some
of the others uh on uh for sites around
stomach have been adopted as spds and
some haven't so you have a fairly mixed
picture this though does not appear to
have been adopted from what I've seen
I've not got notes about the committee
reporting process because this happened
some years ago
and in relation to the access point Brad
are you able to get the slide back up
which shows the concept plan and coming
back to the question of what what's a
conceptual number about about about
houses that the document itself
is a little vague I suppose around uh
what it proposes it certainly proposes
more dwellings than were anticipated in
the allocation itself in the snow Market
error action plan but
uh just to come back to the roundabout
Point
um the design brief very clearly
bigger anticipation design brief very
clearly
shows two red arrows one enters what is
otherwise known as Ash's film itself
this is known as diapers farm and and so
access off the roundabout has not been
part of the parts of this concept for
some years now
um the status of the land around that
roundabout I think is
something that would be very sensible to
resolve I'm not sure that should
distract us from debate this morning
Channel thank you
okay so uh we had a couple more
questions before we move
so is yeah um paragraph 6.16 the
electric vehicle charging
um are we in relation to the to the sort
of rear parking courts
um are we getting trunking to those so
it can be installed or what's what's the
arrangement there
and
um then another question
the is at 1428
uh it looks as if we were going to get
some more from
from
um County highways
um on on that point and I'm not sure
that I I picked that up anywhere as we
went along in your report so
um should we leave that at two for a
moment and I'll see another one at the
end
uh yes thank you councilor I mean in
terms of the the PV issue
um
the situation is that the requirements
of the guidance will be met
so where you've got um on-site or on
plot parking yeah there'll be charging
points provided where they're remote
then there'll be
um the infrastructure put in the the
trunking whatever trunking in order if
there's a requirement to put that in
later there's a facility in order to do
it yeah that yeah that's what I'm asking
so the answer is yes well that's good
right sorry I should have said that
um what was it the other one was 1428
yes
um I see you know there was a verbal
update that was coming so I
I thought I'd make sure we've got that
or you may have had it last time you see
that's the problem for me
um problem because every committee we
start at the beginning and run through
it all so yeah
the word sorry the the way my report's
written
um that comment in 1428 specifically
relates to
at that point about the priority but the
the actual Highway Authority comments
which were awaited the whole comment
these were released received separately
the whole commentary are included later
on in that before yeah
rather than becomes a light paper so
apologies for the confusion of that yeah
yes
um
and that is oh yes and very very
relevant this week
um in in the proposed
um
conditions conditions and conditions
um yeah are we covering the the issue of
um surface water management during
construction because we've had another
very bad episode in the finbara road in
my ward
um both sites of deluges of water
flowing off both sites are under
construction
are we covering that as a separate
condition I've seen it somewhere as a
separate condition but you've asked the
question is it a condition we don't need
more than that thank you it's not
drafted as a separate condition but we
could add that
yeah
just two two questions have I made
please for clarification uh Bradley uh
on slide 60 could we have a look at that
one again please
I think it was slide 16.
yeah going up the Stow Upland Road as
you come where it branches off to the
right to the Uplands estate the the
actual tarmac footpath ends
that's still up the road where it
branches off is are there plans as part
of this application to tarmac the 100
meters up until the roundabout runs
outside the road as well that's my first
question please no no okay and my second
question the residents in woodlark Drive
which is opposite the roundabout they
are very concerned about the flats
particularly the the Upper Floor of the
flats that they'll be able to look into
their bedrooms can I have sort of
confirmation that they will not be able
to do that because obviously that that's
um
major concern of them
um well I think Council there will be
views available undoubtedly I mean the
as I said in the the presentation uh
we're looking to
um landscape the corner of that site in
order to
soften the impact but obviously that
takes time to to grow but
notwithstanding that the the distance
between the two
um across the road as well
um we don't think that there was a a
supportable reason to to con you know
concern with overlooking in that
particular particular sense of front to
front distance rather than front in to
back as well
thanks bats Council mayor did you want
to come in
no okay sorry cancel the field
thank you just to return to the um the
comments from the sustainability officer
I was wondering how we discuss how we
tackle that the comments seem to imply
that uh we can't make a decision yet
um so let's delay things
um let's um
yet again
okay I just want to take that a bit
further
um certainly looking yesterday sat 10.2
doesn't yet appear to be available for
domestic properties it is for commercial
properties but there's a trial
application which sits on government
websites which one could use if one was
enthusiastic enough
clearly the issue is that at the moment
electricity gives you about
231 grams of CO2 per kilowatt generated
gas is about 215 slightly better however
if you stick a air source heat pump in
because of the the gain that figure
comes down to 108 grams per kilogram so
that there's clearly a benefit from
climate point of view of things to gain
which is what was concerning the
committee was just wondering how we're
really going to resolve that
in a way that perhaps doesn't just kick
this into the long glass for another not
a reconstructive period
Philip
thank you Jim
um one option would be to
um
effectively delegate to myself to get
the full sap calculations that Mr
Chisholm is looking for
and to get those in a satisfactory
format that enable the comparisons he
wants to do so that we can then conclude
whether or not what's offered is
um the optimum Arrangements which I
think is what we're all trying to
achieve here to reduce CO2 so
um and a subject to giving that some
thoughts to the wording chairman the
first point would be that one needs the
information to establish what the facts
are about the proposal and its
permutations and then to settle upon the
permutation that achieves the optimum
arrangements for the reduction of CO2
and require those by conditions and and
one could put that as a headline
delegation beneath which everything else
sits Jen
yeah or the applicant could turn around
and say they're doing SOC pumps
throughout today
we haven't yet heard from them chairman
uh could one just say that you know the
thing is not to rivet ourselves into
that position but perhaps to except for
Philips eye
okay we'll move on then thank you very
much so we'll now move on to speakers uh
so first of all
um like to invite the parish council we
don't have anyone from the parish
council but we've obviously seen their
comments we don't have an objector and
we don't have a supporter but we do have
the agent we have Richard Clues and
David Fletcher from Stratton Parker then
Daniel Wilson from Crest Nicholson
Raymond long from Richard Jackson and
Andrew McManus from aesc
so I don't know who's going to go first
but over to you and if you can please
keep the three minutes
thank you thank you
um thank you chairing chairman good
morning members
um the application obviously was
presented previously to the committee
with a recommendation to approval and
we're very pleased it does so again
today
um I'll concentrate on the changes that
we've made since the previous committee
as we will presume that all the other
aspects were essentially well received
and supported just as a quick summary
the application has been subject to
detailed discussions prior to submission
and throughout the determination
including over the last few weeks on the
final few matters for completeness does
include engagement with constantees such
as the highway Authority the llfa and
Council we've also worked very closely
with the applicants for Ash's Farm to
ensure a coordinated delivery on the
cycle pedestrian and vehicular
connections which we know is important
and also Collective contributions
towards the junction improvements and
the bus services as you as you heard
previously the application was deferred
in order to consider the design of units
close to the A14 look at the triple Park
in cycle charging for e-cycles confirmly
designed the toucan Crossing and
sustainable energy proposals and above
standards we've addressed each of these
with officers as you heard earlier on
the cycle charging these have been
entirely agreed and the two can Crossing
design you have seen already in the
presentation
regards to the design of the of the
apartment buildings we've changed that
design so actually now One Wing of it
actually now faces into the side so it's
not just the location isn't the same
sorry location is the same but the but
the arrangement the building has
actually changed
um so that we no longer faces towards
the A14
this enhances the design in terms of the
public realm as expressed by officers in
the report we've also changed the
external appearance the detailing and
the roof pitches all of which have been
supported Landscaping has been clarified
between the apartments and the
surrounding roads and will be planted
with Native hedging and trees to soften
the building levels have been clarified
to show the apartment building how it
would be seen from stomach and Roses
virtually a two-story building and also
the views over the A14 will look
essentially over the countryside rather
than over the road and we hope that was
that was clear from those section plans
with your officers it was agreed that
the orientation of the rest of the
properties is actually best as or as
currently proposed with the private
Gardens facing into the site rather than
towards the April team in combination
with the acoustic fence and the planting
these will protect this will protect
residential amenity
on the triple parking the layout has
been revised to reduce the amount of
triple parking by two dwellings and
importantly we've increased the visitor
parking from 65 to 74 spaces which is
nine more than the standards would
require this is to help prevent
unauthorized parking and the industrial
spaces are all proposed closest to those
properties that have the triple parking
the plots of triple parking are all
served of private drives and officers
have confirmed this Accords with the
adopted parking standards
on sustainability following concerns
raised by members about the limited
number of dwellings that would have that
would have benefited from the previous
proposal which was SRT pumps across a a
minority of the site about third of the
site crests are fully afraid the time is
up so it'll have to be the last sentence
please well we have the sustainability
officer with us who can go through all
the details but there is substantial
improvement over existing building
regulations
um
and
um those can also be adapted as the
scheme goes on as building regulation
change we have our Consultants here if
you have any questions thank you
okay questions we'll start on the barrel
councilman
thank you um for your brief and um as a
member of the committee that looked at
this before thank you for addressing
some of our concerns
um I think
the air assault heat pump and PV panels
remains an issue for me
um
in that committee it was I think my
interpretation of the committee's wishes
that they were Keen to see more air
source heat pumps and PV panels being
offered as an option
can you confirm that actually what
you're doing is offering PV panels on
available houses those that can take it
and you've taken out the heat Source
pump option
yes so I'll I'll respond to that firstly
but then I'll let Andrew who's our state
business consultant come up further what
we did was we reviewed the strategy
entirely because members I believe the
actual request was that purchases have
the option of buying PV panels if on
their site instead of doing that we're
actually proposing them across all of
the properties
um as part of the build so instead of
our source heat pumps there's now PV
panels on on every dwelling that means
that all of the occupiers benefit from
renewable technology that's the caveat
is where practical
um but we but but that that's the offer
is all the ways to benefit from PV when
you look at the CO2 and I'll let Andrew
responses properly
um that actually is a big Improvement
compared to air source heat pumps
um and I'll let Andrew explain the the
facts and figures around that but that's
it actually worked out as a as a win-win
situation to actually provide PV across
all the sites rather than Airsoft heat
pumps on some of the properties yeah
thank you for that I listened to the
um letter written by uh read out by the
officer and understood very little of it
my concerns are far more practical
if you put in what I assume are gas
boilers at some point as a resident I'm
gonna have to take that out and put in
another source of heating that will
probably incur higher costs because I'm
going to have to install on the floor
heating or larger radiators so I don't
actually see
you've now putting PV panels on those
houses that can take them but you are
condemning the residents to large
payments at some time in the future
where they can't replace their gas
boiler and they're going to be forced
into another form of e-text so I think
looking at just CO2 now is is only part
of the issue for me and that that may be
just my lack of understanding so
I think some of this comes back to the
the great oh sorry Andrew malice
associate director at as sustainability
Consultants
um some of it comes back to the
regulatory Baseline it was discussed you
know the different carbon factors under
the different ranks and things so I
think it's worth explaining that
initially the initial parcel will be
assessed under the partel 2013 regime
and we've committed to delivering a
roughly 20 carbon reduction on those
units by by adding solar panels to the
homes which previously didn't didn't
have
now going forward to parse L 21
there is software available to do those
calculations so we have we have run
those calculations
um the strategy for those homes
initially will be to to supply with gas
plus PV which is similar to adjacent
developments the broad homeless
development which I understand has been
approved so following that strategy is
fully in accordance with the regulatory
standards and the direction of travel
that the government is saying we need to
go to we know the future home standard
may come in into effect in 2025 and at
that point um SOC pumps are likely to
become the kind of de facto standard but
at this point in time we don't
necessarily know that's a definite we
don't obviously know that they are a low
carbon solution we know the grid is
decarbonizing
um but the very significant concern
about running costs for homeowners
electricity prices being what they are
you know when the price cap comes to an
end we know they are going to be very
expensive to run AP ratings will be
worse for the houses with their sort
pumps than with the gas plus PV so from
an affordability perspective I think
it's it's not certainly a bad option to
have a gas plus PV approach in the
interim and then obviously being fully
adaptable to to accommodate future
changes to the regulatory standards
so so why don't you just go for air
source throughout
um I think is it is it Finance
I think there's a number of of issues
around some of this so uh
there's an impression that the whole
industry can just move to SOC pumps
today to achieve these carbon
Productions there's a massive shortage
of kind of design and installation
competent and expertise in the industry
is that Crest doesn't have the expertise
in that field is that the problem no
it's an independent designers obviously
Crest wouldn't would employ the the heat
pump designers and manufacturers to
design those systems and to install them
um if they're designed to install you
know by people who don't have a lot of
experience in doing it then they can
perform very poorly actually and a lot
of the bad press that heat pumps have
had great sir I'm just I can't I'm going
to have to challenge that we've got two
applications before us today one that's
doing 100 S or seat punks tell it's not
a problem at all and they're another
National house Builder and you telling
us there is a problem so that'll be for
the committee to decide but you know
we've got two applications in front of
us giving totally different views on the
same subject
there's a lot of things to it I think
another is electrical capacity and I
don't know a chance to have a look at
some of the issues around that uh well
well I'm sure we'll cover it in debates
um
keep going around the room cancer even
um thank you chair thank you for your
comments earlier um I've got two
questions if I may um firstly about the
gas infrastructure because presumably if
you're if you're putting an air source
heat pumps you wouldn't have to
um
install
um huge pipes throughout the whole site
which I suspect would not only in the
expense but also a lot of carbon so um
have you
um factored that in um
with your kind of costs and things in
terms of it being obviously therefore
cheaper to have vessels heat bumps and
secondly
um
could you just advise what you're
expecting your build out rate to to be
um and I ask this in that um
you know the residents around the area
won't want to kind of prolonged
construction site for five seven ten
years or whatever
um and with the news um today that
several major house builders I'm not
sure yours was one of them have said
that they are struggling
um with sales at the moment and are
therefore reducing their their build out
rate so if you could comment on what you
expect for 250 homes the the build-out
rate to be thank you
thank you um so first of all on the on
the infrastructure course obviously that
is that he's um captured
um within with all of all the
assessments that they're untaken I think
it should be emphasized again that the
gas plus PV is cheaper for the occupiers
um particularly at the moment there's
there's also um even though you'll have
the gas infrastructure putting obviously
the pipe work
um if you have all the air SRT pumps
you've then got extra electricity load
and you need additional substations so
so electricity infrastructure to install
um which which may or may it's not seem
easier from public perspective but but
the approach here is have gas plus PV
which is which has been seen to be um
approach for all round for lowering
carbon and also fertile costs
particularly for the occupiers of the
drawings in the future on the build out
rates I think it's about 50 dwellings
per annum 50 to 60 dwellings per annum
is is typical in a site such as this
yes I know that's typical but I'm saying
recently we're always told it's 50 to
60. so I know that's the typical build
out rate but I'm asking you in the
current circumstances with sales you
know and this site isn't going to be
start being built for another you know
if it gets approval today it won't start
being built for a set amount of time so
what would you expect to build out rate
for this this site to be
oh
afternoon all Don Wilson from Crest
Nicholson thank you for your question
um we have done very recent market
research on this site a month ago and
we've seen no fall off in terms of
persons who would like to purchase in
the local area we've got a site up the
road in handygate and that is something
that is progressing quite quickly so in
terms of seeing between 56 60 a year
that's something that we're confident
that can happen in terms of the market
at present time
thank you
keep going along the background did you
want to come in nope down to the front
row Council Matheson
thank you yes
um a note in the recommendations that
we've got
um
some ground floor one bedroom flats and
we're
um
recommending the office is recommending
that they will have level access showers
not bars I wondered whether
um I'm not sure how many of them there
actually are but I wonder whether we
could have some of those two
m42 and perhaps one to m43
standard of construction
so we probably have to just check what
the um what the standards are for those
already
um if they've got level access
um and they've got the wider corridors
then then it may be straightforward but
we would need to we would need to check
that to see whether m43 could be
achieved but I assume they are waiting
for two
um because they're the ground floor
Apartments but I would need to check
that with you
offer on this thing
yes
yes I think now yes so they would
typically be be sort of be arranged by
the um by the pressure provider
um and they would typically request
things such as m42 or m43 as part of
that deal I I honestly would need to
check the um the the plans and see
whether they're in Port three or really
do that while we're just debating
um possibly
thank you uh Council field did you have
anything oh thank you
yes
I guess your
when you spell you're implying that um
the the 2013 regulations imply that at
the moment one should use gas boilers
because they're based on
various numbers that come from 2013 not
2022.
and that if we move to the 2021
regulations uh the then the picture will
change and it's clear then that
um the decarbonization of the grid
effects the choices that one was making
do I understand that correctly oh yes
there's a point
so that seems to a
ffect cancer Reborns point which is well
my my interpretation of this is how many
dwellings do you expect to be built out
under the 2013 regulations before you
have to change to the situation that
exists today rather than the historical
data
you did make a number of points about
you know the efficiency of air source
heat pumps and that sort of thing I only
have figures here which are relatively
informal so difficult to hacks use them
as part of a decision but clearly what
you're saying is not really supported
um that the the the cost and carbon from
Pure electric heating would be high the
cost of carbon from
gas heating is
where the carbons comparable the cost is
substantially lower than the electric
heating if you move to air source heat
pumps the carbon is clearly dramatically
less
that the car cost is comparable
it's slightly more I have to say for air
Soul seat and slightly less for grounds
will see so there are a set of things
which you know really
how are we going to tackle we clearly
wish to move to the Future you seem to
be accepting that the the regulations
which are just about appearing actually
will point exactly in the direction of
the committee is requiring
but you're not going to do it yet
because you're working to an older set
of building rings do I understand those
things correctly or am I wrong
so neither partel 2013 or part L 21
which is the two regulatory standards
that we have definition of neither of
them are prescriptive over which heating
system needs to be used so parcel 21
won't mandate air source heat pumps for
some housing types they might be the
most appropriate type particularly where
there's roof area constraints that the
amount of PV that you would otherwise
require to meet the current reduction
targets doesn't fit on the roof
certainly the bulk of homes that we'll
see built to parcel 21 will be gas plus
BB and we work with a lot of national
developers and that is the current
Solution that's being proposed part of
that is due to due to the the cost and
availability of the heat pump systems
and the installers but part of it is
down to that being the most appropriate
um
Approach at this point in time with a
view to moving towards the future home
standard in 2025 which is is not yet
defined so we don't have a lot of detail
about that but the expectation is that
that will be a heat pump load solution
um councilman I think it was concerned
about people needing to retrofit their
houses and about the
um the the design basically of the the
heat emitting devices the radiators and
underfloor heating and their ability to
deal with the lower flow temperatures
from
carbon free heating sources air sauce or
ground salts or whatever heat pumps do
you intend to fit the houses with heat
emitters which will which will ensure we
can move to low carbon heat sources
without extensive rework or or not yeah
so that is a requirement of the partel
21 regulations that the the heating
system should be designed for a lower
flow temperature that's a suitable for
heat pumps so that will be part of those
names will be adaptable therefore to go
to heat pumps in the future
thank you so the 2013 ones won
sorry
the ones you built to 2013 standards
will not be readily adapted
and that's something we'll have to have
a look at
cancer Humphries uh Mr chair thank you
so listen to all of this and um
cop 27 sitting at the moment and we're
all looking for our leaders to make
decisions to save the world and all of
us are demanding this and we're
demanding that the demanding the rest
but actually we've all got a part to
play every single one of us including
news developers as you've said there are
developers have gone 100 you'll tell
them it's the supply issue well that's
not a reason for not doing it right it's
a reason to work harder to actually
deliver it when we talk about costs
we're not in debate no no it's a
question it will come to a question but
I wanted to make that point
um I could do it in debate right and I
probably will again my question is this
what is the real reason you're not doing
it what is the real reason that you're
not looking forward to next regulations
and trying to save the planet and why
you're not trying to save people money
so these are questions and the other
thing you talked about lots of figures
you started waffling on about
electricity prices subsidies and
everything else the truth of it is this
the electricity and gas prices are
slightly inflated at the moment due to a
war all Wars come to an end when that
end of the war comes those prices will
adjust so it's not about the price of
electricity for the consumer it's
exactly what councilman said is about
the cost to bring you to the question
yeah it replaces one of you so my
question is my question is my
fundamental question is this why are you
not doing the right thing
so thank you very much for your question
I think it's very helpful for us to go
back to when you were here at the last
planning committee we were asked to do
we came here and we presented
information based upon what the policy
requirements are and at that point in
time we went above policy requirements
we then asked by the committee to go
back and see whether we could come up
with a better scheme in terms of energy
and we were given reference to the blur
home scheme which was only
permitted in the summer this year that
scheme in particular had a combination
of air of um PV and gas so we went we
went away we looked at the schemes we
looked up was done in the local vicinity
by and that was permitted by this very
committee we change our entire energy
strategy and we came back to something
which was above police requirement that
is something that is good for the
environment and something that the
committee requested so it seems a bit
perverse if I might say so that we're
asked no to again go and change the gold
post every time we come back to
committee we are doing what the
committee has asked really sorry but
you're absolutely not doing what the
committee asked you were here we asked
you to go away and look at air source
seat pumps throughout you've come back
and said you're not doing it I've got
two questions why which is cheaper to
build gas or electric or ground Source
heat pumps air source heat pumps which
is cheaper and how much cheaper is gas
because that's the obvious answer
secondly if you had to build an
electricity substation who would pay for
it you or power networks and is that why
there's no extra substation going in
we've got to get to the bottom of this
you've got to be truthful you're not
telling us the truth it doesn't make
sense to an average person as to why
you're building half an estate with gas
that's an old technology when we are
wanting residents to have future and a
better life in a future technology and
you're just not giving us the real
answers you're just giving us regulation
after regulation we're not happy you can
tell that by the committee so
sexual facts why are you not building
gas is it cheaper
well no I'll come I'll come back on the
I think I thought about the cost point
because I don't know it was a town
planner it's not my not my field
um the air source heat pumps the the
issue were there was about
um improving upon uh building standards
that's what we're actually asked to do
it was it was about whether whether
Crest I think the actual requested where
the crest could provide the ability to
purchase PV panels from occupy so that
would be that would be a choice when
they when they choose to put their money
down on the home
um and to whether we could exceed
building regulations building standards
when we looked at that energy mix we
actually realized that that PV powers on
every dwelling was a was actually better
than airsoft's heat pumps uh which were
provided before it actually exceeds the
building regulations across the entire
development throughout the development
rather than just at the later time and
we also didn't have the noise issue
which was which was something that came
up with the airsoft heat pumps when that
was proposed we were also asked to to
undertake a noise assessment on that
side of things which was actually raised
today and of course we're now talking
about removing PD rights for occupiers
so they can't retrofit it without
planning consent for airsoft's heat
pumps there's clearly another issue
around Ash we've heard all this you've
told us this already so would you have
to build the substation yes or no a
substation would have to be put in I
assume that would have to be crests
which would have to be built if the
whole place was ground Source heat pumps
and air source heat pumps so now we've
got to the root of the problem that is
the reason why because the substation
presume you would have to go well I'll
let Andrew the actual reason is because
we reviewed the energy strategy and it
was clearly better to provide PP to
everyone
no no for the for the residents and also
for
um for for everyone to benefit from
renewable technology rather than just
some occupies and again this does go
beyond building regs at the moment it
clearly meets local plan policy and we
we actually felt it was a better
approach obviously it's a very reaction
of the committee it's a move on to
question it's very visible thank you
benefit as well we'll go to Council on
there next you know just you say you're
going to put PV panels on houses where
it's appropriate how many houses in the
development will it be inappropriate to
put PV panels on
so I'll I'll see where there's a there's
an update on that um our approach is 100
the caveat of where practical came from
the Bloor homes development where that
was the that was the requirement on them
so we've used the same language there
but the the intention is to is to
Endeavor to meet it on on every property
we need to do an assessment about which
ones would be impractical
um realistically that would probably be
those with the with the most complex
roof shapes or those that that only only
have suitable rooms that would face
North even then I think you could
probably get something out of them but
but that that practical part came from
the language from the decision on
another on on the blore homes
application
um that one ended up with about 50 of
all the homes but we are proposing 100
percent
but with the same language of unless
it's unless it's impractical it's
probably a better way to put it
okay
um
talk about that another one the road
surfaces will they built be built to
adoptable standards and will they be
offered for adoption to the County
Council
um all right
answer that
good morning Raymond long associate
Richard Jackson the answer is yes
thank you
thank you
um yeah caps the field reminded me um of
something that struck me when I was
reading the papers
are the um you know in terms of the
lower flow temperatures
of the air source heat pump approach
um are all the all the properties going
to have um underfloor Heating
because I think that's part and parcel
of the of the air source heat pump
approach but will that be done anyway
with the gas or whoever whatever the
heating is
um they won't be on the floor heating
um the the radiators will be designed in
size to the appropriate size so they can
accommodate that low flow temperature uh
typically where you have underfloor
heating you have underfloor on the
ground floor and then RADS on on the
first floor it does tend to mean that
the the heat from the heat pump needs to
be Blended down to accommodate the lower
flow Temp and the slightly higher temp
which actually means the heat pumps
don't operate energy any more
efficiently than having RADS through is
something we have a little
bit looked at this massive benefit um it
can lead to increased cycling if the
heat pump so it means actually doesn't
last as long as well
one other Cherry if I may
um the when when the officer was um
outlining the the whole proposal
um he described the the south facing
slope of the land as a constraint I
always see it as an opportunity but have
you have you attempted to align and
Orient the the build the properties to
maximize the solar the passive solar
gain
thank you the um the the arrangement is
mostly orientated around the the site
that sells the A14 the access points and
the Urban Design
um the the passive solar gain I think
you can see actually the the scheme does
seem to lend itself uh quite quite well
to that because of the way the way the
site
is orientated towards the southern
corner but no that it was mostly in
Urban Design and to follow the design
brief for the for the um for the site
and the saap
anyone else got questions handsome
answer
um back to the the subject of PV panels
uh you're going to put them on all plots
where they're reasonably practicable
um how many what's the sort of power
output
um just just saying we're going to put
them on all plots mean you're going to
get one
um what what is the offer yep it's uh
the estimates of these two panels per
dwelling
um the power output I will ask Andrew to
uh to confirm that but it but the the
estimate is at least two on each and
every dwelling and that's how the
calculations have been worked out
um Andrew do you have anything to add to
that
um only so the the panel output will be
based on sort of what's available in the
Market at the time um that has been
fluctuating quite a lot at the moment
because of supply issues so uh probably
400 watt panels sort of a 0.8 kilowatt
um system which means that most energy
would be used in the home rather than
exported
Council field
he's going to invite the gentleman to
say that again because I must admit I
didn't hear from what was actually said
two
also it seems to be a low quality most
dwellings will Mount 8 or 16.
I was going to also point out I asked
the The View deal calculations on the
benefits of the of such panels take into
account the fact that uh certainly in my
car to Suffolk it gets quite dark in the
winter and it's quite sunny in the
summer and
heating during the winter when it's also
cold so
issue of the solar panels feeding your
heating system don't occur they tend to
provide lots of power when you don't
need it
I'm not sure how to answer the question
specifically um obviously yes there is a
difference between when the PB panels
are most effective in generation and
when the highest heating load is but
obviously the if you have a system that
sized appropriately for the home then
that means that the maximum impossible
can be used within the home rather than
just being exported to the grid where
it's often actually just just lost so I
appreciate that that kind of a you know
two panel system perhaps isn't the
optimum that was a response to As I
understood at the comments that said you
know all homes should benefit from PV
which is the comments that I've I've
read obviously it would be more
efficient to have fewer larger systems
which is what is on the blower
development and what they've proposed so
if you have fewer larger systems then
you reduce the amount of kind of balance
of system components and inverters and
things so you reduce the embodied carbon
but we're responding to to the comments
we see to say all home should benefit
from PV so that's that's the change that
we made all right so I'm going to have
to follow that up so what you've said is
all houses will benefit from PV so
you're going to put the absolute minimum
number of panels on which is two
is just what we Face the calculations on
at the moment to show the carbon savings
that would be delivered through that
that approach um that's a token
what is what was requested as my
understanding it wasn't actually anyway
councilman yeah
on memory isn't as good as it used to be
um but I was at that committee meeting
and I believe what we asked for was the
option for people to have access to PV
panels not that they should be on every
house
I would really suggest you go and listen
to the tapes they're publicly available
I think we need to move on but he's
getting we're going round and round in
circles on the same thing I haven't even
got on to uh our other request around
triple parking would you care to comment
on why that's still we still have triple
parking on the site you chose not to
take that out
so thank you so the the triple parking
um we discussed this with with officers
and
um it's in accordance with standards
they are they are triple Park is
acceptable off of private drives which
is the only locations where we've got
triple parking
um to to uh reassure the the members um
a little further on the parking capacity
generally we've increased the visitor
parking particularly around those plots
where the where the shared services are
are present so we've now got
um nine additional
um uh visitor parking spaces which is
above requirements
um the triple parking does occult with
the parking standards and we've actually
reduced the triple parking Bay is on two
properties anyway
um so there seem to be an overall
benefit
um and Appliance with with the local
plans the common theme again you've done
the minimum but you could have done so
much more if you'd wanted to so you've
done the minimum yes you've ticked the
box of meeting with minimum parking
standards but this committee asked if
you could take away triple talking so
you've done the minimum which seems to
be this common theme so yes correct you
have met the standards well we've
exceeded the standards on visitor
parking yeah you could have done more
um
uh we'll now move on to the ward Members
First of all we have well we have two
Ward members who would like to go first
here's it's behind you
[Laughter]
thank you very much chair thank you
Carter uh yes
um for this particular application Stone
Market Town Council are still very
unhappy of the lack of Engagement
between the developer and the Town
Council and the issues raised earlier by
the Town Council and also in the late
papers that still apply and are still
considered to be relevant despite the
changes to the plans
okay yes you have reduced some of the
triple parking but really it's not
acceptable I live on Cedar's Park
it's it's awful the parking people don't
use them they park on the Pavements so
it's nice to see you've got some more
visitor parking spaces but from my
experience and I walk past them every
day it's it's the people that got more
than you know two or three cars they use
all those they can't be used by visitor
parking
I'm not going to go into the issues
already raised by fellow members which I
totally support and agree with regarding
the heat Source uh air heat Source pumps
Etc another issue I do have concerns
about is the proposed Timber play
equipment on the open space
I would urge the developer to reconsider
and have steel play equipment and the
reason I say that is there's a small
play area on Cedars park at the bottom
of siskin Street and the top of
Partridge close with Timber equipment
it's never used it's fell into disrepair
and all the other areas on Cedar's Park
that have still play equipment are well
used by local children
tree planting should be strengthened to
offset the carbon footprint of
developing the site I am particularly
concerned about the disturbance of the
surface of the former chicken farm which
may release stored carbon into the
atmosphere
I've also spoken to quite a lot of
residents
um within the ward and the main issues
that they are concerned about is perhaps
on the periphery of the actual planning
but they are concerned about the density
of the housing proposed on this piece of
land is excessive
despite the proposed sale payments
towards the NHS according to the
response received on April 22 from the
NHS between the two surgeries in Stone
Market there are only 38 vacancies for
new patients at present no local
dentists are taking on new NHS patients
the nearest local primary schools on
Cedars Park and in Stowe Upland are
currently full the result is children
will have to travel to other schools
across the town which will invariably
mean they will be taken by car because
there is insufficient public transport
to move them by that which will increase
congestion across the town as well as
increasing the amount of air pollution
and I can assure you gentlemen that that
is particularly bad when the crossing
gates are down and the trains are going
past I've witnessed it myself
so although I welcome the funding for
the proposed bus service although not a
planning consideration as such I do
support the idea mentioned in the papers
of a local bus service linking all the
estate in stone market and Stow Upland
I also welcome proposals for the toucan
crossing the emergency access to the
site that the existing public
right-of-way is upgraded to a bridal
wave status and the development of a
three meter cycleway connecting with the
spine road with the ashes farm
development so there are some positives
in this but I must concur with what
stone Market Town councilor said and
overall unfortunately I cannot support
this application thank you
the other award member wants to go next
to them or take questions
thank you thank you um yeah it's
wonderful to be back for its
developments and what a time it's been
that's a time you know
uh three PMS I think it's been two uh
five year turns or so and we can see all
this time of changing this development
we look at and um
well that building's been changed and
there's a picture of a road plan and
the wall writing but
anyway
um
I've been sat here as a war counselor
I've also sat through the planning we
had at the Stow Market Town Council
and
it's a bit better doing a bare minimum
on there as well when documentation that
we have here we had a pretty picture of
red and blue houses and none of the
information
that's just trying to engage the local
community is not even tried
um
I can see some differences to this
application formed previously it's
obviously alignments were one of the
presidency at rear but the objections
made by the Town Council and concerns by
the community team are still extremely
valid in that
in my opinion the affordable housing
still at the worst least favorable parts
of the developments
and I share concerns with members
regarding how the housing density and
councilman's rights indeed that there
are no bungalows in this application and
uh
I will say most questions I have
whenever someone is remotely in favor of
a bleeding Health housing development is
is there going to be a bungalow we need
more Bungalows but I assume it's not in
favor of the favorite location
um
it's been wonderful sitting here and
members have already picked up on lack
of well changing to solar but it's the
sadness of loss of ASP HBS
reducing foot every property negating
the need for costly information of that
gas infrastructure which we are due to
be phasing out
um there's been some arguing about the
amount of carbon I will say that figures
I've read That's indeed if gas is left
on constantly the carbon figures are
lower but if you're turning on and off
your heating is going to raise up raise
up the gas carbon burn and it'd be more
costly to residents
and with it being phrased out again but
it residents who have to if walkout for
a changing
and I would say it's perverse with
developers as we say renewable for
everyone when it's especially
questionable how effective these two
solar panels will be we're not every
property is aligned correctly but make
best usage of the Sun
and if promise it provides soda for all
three properties where possible when all
properties should be aligned and made
property properly for the best benefit
and as with councilman for play area
remains some a great concern to me
now in in town and stay Forney there are
already many examples of smell
ill-maintained and poorly placed play
equipment which see little to no usage
of
now this poorly placed Pockets apart
we've played Vision cited at the top
intends to go one step further
the current placement backs onto the A14
regardless of the of the world Place
noise and air pollution in this area
will be of its highest
and especially during winter when Leaf
relief density would be low
for children they're smaller undeveloped
lung capacities being of greater risk to
air contaminants
and for those with breathing
difficulties such as asthma or sensory
issues with this noise of the road will
be a greatest issue but Place placement
of such play provision at this area may
make it unattainable unattainable to
them
so there's many things regardless
development which are questionable
many things that's
I can't well
I'd move not to be on in favor so it
could be doing so much more
and you could actually engaged River
residents engage with the town
engagement communities which have been
trying to reach out to try and
betterment with this thing this
development and make it actually
suitable
instead of doing just a bare minimum so
thank you
thanks very much I just got a one
question did Chris Nicholson come to a
town council meeting to present the
application at all
they previously did once didn't listen
to any other comments made
um didn't get it didn't actually answer
to any uh Furby asks questions for
engagement okay thank you yeah
right so we'll move on
well can we go into debate and then
break after the debate because I think
we're in the flow I think this Punch
Yeah well can you go for another 15-20
minutes hufner
extracts from the
device I don't want to distract you John
okay we'll take a quick five minute
break but can I just remind everyone not
to discuss the application at all during
the break please
okay okay so welcome back everyone
um so thank you so we're now on to uh
really
um opening up the debate discussion
um around the application for us but
just before we do that
um Philip you just got something you'd
like to bring up
thank you chairman yes I I just wondered
if I could
um ask the applicants whether they have
given any consideration to the debate
that's taken place thus far and uh
whether they've got anything that they
can contribute in terms of uh the
potential for a condition to manage what
they're offering chairman so if with
your permission
thank you thank you so uh yeah
absolutely you've been listening to the
to the debate in detail and
um while we felt we had met what members
were principally asking for
um and we've got the data show that what
we've just been discussing with Chris
Nicholson
um the approach is still gas plus PV
across the entire side but we can also
offer um air source heat pumps as a
purchase option which which was the
request by members as a purchase option
for the first occupiers
um instead of a gas connection so they
they could choose to have the air source
heat pumps instead of the gas connection
um and that that was the request we
would stick with the PV across across
the site and offer that as a as an
option
um that's a condition which has if we
can agree this as a daily as a planning
condition
um that we have had on Henley gate which
is in the Ipswich area uh the garden
suburb for there so so we are able to
implement this
um as a proposal just to be clear the
gas is the option but people have the
option of purchasing in to converting
now rather than doing it to the later
date at their cost note the the other
way so the other way around the
standards gas plus PV across the side as
per the energy strategy
um but every the first occupiers the
first purchases would have the option to
buy SRT pumps instead of the gas
connection which which doesn't doesn't
make any difference to the to the homes
themselves it's literally just the way
it's connected the retrofit is actually
quite straightforward these days um but
it would be as a purchase option
yeah
so they would have to pay for that for
that X as an extra
the SRT pump would be an extra but the
PV panels are still proposed as a
standard across the inside site
okay well thank you for coming back to
that I appreciate that okay so we're
going to debate so first up is councilor
Humphries
Mr thank you compromise is always a
great thing isn't it thank you for that
already
um so in principle I support the
development of this site it's been a
long time coming in in fairness
um so there's certain parts that I like
I like to come across in I like the open
space like the tree planting scheme and
the um
the connection side of it including the
cycle path so it's all that's good
um the access is the access and as we've
heard we can't change that is what it is
it would be great for being around about
life's not like that is it so
unfortunately it's the way we are
um I'd also like the ideas that's privy
throughout I think it's a great idea I'm
not an expert on it I've Got My Views as
you've probably heard but I'm not an
expert so I don't know if two's enough
or three is enough or Four's enough
that's not my my decision I do know
actually that it doesn't it doesn't
always matter about the orientation of
the house you still get uh PV working in
different orientations obviously it's
not as good uh itself it's better in
Southwest but it is what it is the
he was doing great if you'd gone 100
um on the
um air sourced heat pumps but I
understand business I understand
everything else about it
um but I think it's nice that you've
compromised it and you're allowing those
first
um
buyers to to change it if they wish to
which is fine and someone's got to pay
In fairness we all pay in the end don't
we so it is what it is
um so
although the regulations the regulations
2013 I'm a forward-looking guy I think
do you know if a regulation is going to
change I've got a business some
regulations in my area are changing next
year I'm already implementing that
change but that's simple for me because
just pens for you guys it's a lot
difficult because you've got Supply so
that is a different issue
um
it is what it is they are the
regulations right now you comply with
those regulations and In fairness
they're going a little bit above and
beyond the current regulations so as far
as the reasons for refusal got to be
very very careful because they are
within the current regulations they're
doing nothing wrong and in areas they're
going a bit further than than they
should
um I'll let everybody else have a voice
obviously but they're My Views at the
moment
so much customers
expect so I was expecting it to be
Council Matheson before me
um uh yeah I am I listened to the
um applicants concession that they've
just come up with and
it's a concession uh I'm not I'm not
convinced it's quite enough
um but anyway first thing I wanted to
say was I'm still a bit concerned about
the three-story apartment block okay
it's had its wing pointing the other way
but there is still a bedroom window on
the third floor which is going to be
above the acoustic fence
and sort of facing the A14 so I'm not
convinced that anyone living there would
want to have their windows open at night
um but I think it's probably about one
bedroom on that top floor apartment
closest to the road uh but okay they've
they've turned that round
um and that hasn't been mentioned yet
um and I the thing I did want to say was
we we obviously didn't make our
intentions clear at the last committee
meeting
because I thought we were sort of asking
for more air source heat pump with the
option of solar panels beefing panels
and we haven't got that at all so was it
that we didn't make ourselves clear or
have we be completely misinterpreted
um
uh I I do you know
I just don't um
I'm just not convinced by it's just a
concession isn't it really let's put a
PV panel on every roof just to keep
those counselors shutting up
um
and as I understood it I I I I I know I
don't I don't use air source heat pumps
myself I don't I don't know that much
about them but my logic tells me that
Airsoft heat pumps use electricity
um in order to generate the in order to
get going in order they're at the back
of a fridge
um so therefore adding PV panels when
you've got an air source heat pump seems
like the obvious thing to do because the
air SOS heat pump require only requires
a small amount of electricity whereas
heating by electricity uses vast amounts
of electricity
so the fact that we've got one or the
other here it was sort of oh we're
taking away the airtel's heat pumps but
we're going to give them polar PV panels
PV panels cannot be used for heating on
their own
um that would take far far too much
electrical power so ah okay we're now
we're now going to allow
um purchases to option air source heat
pumps so I'll probably need to have a
bit of a rethink about whether I want to
support this or not before that
concession came in I wasn't really
prepared to support it
um but on the plus side I think
extending the bike path on the off side
of starpler road
is great because at the moment that's
just a grassy Verge so I think that is
an improvement having a um a toucan
Crossing on onto the Upland Road is
great I like the
um cycle permeability between that and
the other estate but I do still I I do
still have my concerns about about this
heating but I'll listen to what other
people are going to say thank you
thanks very much councilman
thank you yeah now I wasn't I wasn't
here to to
um to take part in the deferral last
time but of course I've I've
being a
speaking about for for years now about
other other um you know last last goal
applications like this one
um and and what what we're trying to
what we're trying to say to developers
you know is is you know someone came up
with it with the phrase fabric first we
thought Yep they're right you the first
thing is to get get the fabric right
well I actually I would say that one
before that is to look at the
orientation because you've got a flat
piece of ground well you get you know
you could get some benefit from doing it
right but once you start getting on
these cell-facing slopes you've got a
huge opportunity and my my friendly
constituent
um architect with us Masters in
sustainability and stuff
um you know he said you can get 20
of a reduction of energy demand
by getting the orientation right and
that's before you even start talking
about what technology you're going to
use and so that's the first thing and
the fabric first is the second thing
because they're the things that you you
are built in they are they are the
bricks and the blocks and all the rest
of it
um before you then say right now how
should we eat it
and then you get to to the issue that
the the the air source heat pump
um as I understand it although maybe I'm
we're hearing not not not so much
um that that requires a particular build
in order to in order to to install it
um and and that that's why retrofitting
essels heat pumps to existing houses is
is difficult and expensive and Council
field as you know pointed to some of the
problems about that so you know that and
and then having decided about that you
then say well
can we vote on something some extra
technology and I remember the the
developers coming in rubbishing
um sort of domestic wind turbines
rightly so
um as a sort of a bolt-on extra kind of
thing rather than tacking the
fundamentals which is the fabric first
so you know that's what we I would
imagine the committee we're asking to
asking you to think through last time
um so so I'm not very happy at all with
with
um with where we've got to so far with
with that
um
readily put on relatively easily put on
PV panels in five years time
um when they're even cheaper than they
are now
um but it is more difficult to put in
air source heat pumps retrospectively
and so I think this close to the wire
still putting in these gas boilers it's
just it just is not the right answer now
whether officers are able to conjure up
the conditions and things which would
allow the committee to get what it wants
um I don't know but I surely would hope
that they can because as the chair has
said we are going to be looking later on
at an application where another
developer has said okay well we give in
aircel's heat pumps the holy State even
though the gas is available which is the
situation here as well
um so I'm not not not very very keen I
do have residual
um
sympathy with the the arguments that the
Town Council has put forward about the
the sort of the generality of it and and
whether the the
access shouldn't be off the roundabout
that's already there
um
you know which is something that sounds
as if it's still achievable from what Mr
Isabella said a lot earlier
um as to whether we ought to keep that
possibility open if if it has sufficient
Advantage but
um I I don't know whether I can't judge
whether it does or it doesn't we've I
see we've got an officer here from
highways who might might give us a a
steer on that but um I think that the
the access is probably the minor issue
compared to getting the Energy System
right thank you let's go around the rest
of the committee then if we need to
bring in office as we can cancel You by
newer next
um thank you very much chair
um
first up I'm I'm concerned about the
lack of community engagement that
there's been on this site I know it's
been in the stem market area action plan
on the cards for kind of probably over
10 years now but just because in that
doesn't mean there shouldn't be constant
and and regular Community engagement so
I'm disappointed that that
um that hasn't been the case and I hope
that the developer won't
um will take a different approach if
they've got any other developments in in
our area
on particular
um
issues with the um the application the
one thing that um a few things I'd like
to kind of pick up on are that there's
still this this gap between in the cycle
access between the southern end of the
site and and the station and I
appreciate that highways have made the
comments saying there isn't enough space
to put in a in a cycle route but I I
just wonder whether there could be any
potentially an informative if this is to
get approved to for people to just to
reconsider and have a look at that route
and just see how we can get people
safely to the to the station
particularly from the site
um
the I'm concerned that the bus route the
planned bus route I think is a great
idea but I'm concerned it's going to
take several years for it to come to
fruition and and I would like to see
some mechanism somehow for us to kind of
keep on that to make sure that actually
does happen
and I think I mentioned um in
questioning about the construction
management plan and ensuring that that
caters for the safety of pedestrians and
cyclists are along starkland Road
just with regard to the issues of
heating of these homes
um
the applicant has referred to a previous
Committee in a previous
um
application
um I I remember that and if they the
applicant had listened to the debate or
watched it on YouTube you'd have heard
the phrase not good enough
from I think just about every single
member on the committee and it was
passed but several members voted against
it and the key issue was about what
building regulations they were following
and whether they were putting in office
heat pumps in etc etc and
I just feel that
you know Chris Nicholson is a national
developer and it seems that they've come
back to us under duress
to kind of um with with the options you
know what you know so there's clearly
their National approach is not to
address issues of sustainability or not
to kind of look to the future or not to
make things easier for their residents
of their of these home the new residents
of these homes in five ten years time
when they're going to have to retrofit
their homes so I find that that kind of
whole attitude a bit
sad really and it's just such a shame
that that is the case and I would have
thought that a developer of this size
would have would have taken more care
um really so I I am very disappointed in
that approach
um
as I say
um yeah overall you know I see the
changes some changes have been made
and you know my my current issue is that
I
think that the outstanding issues
probably aren't enough to Warrant
refusal but I'm just not very happy and
to use the phrase I used back in back in
the committee meeting of the application
you keep quoting is just not good enough
so
um you know major house builders
should be doing better
um but I'll leave it there thank you
chair
thank you Council field you were next
thank you I avoid saying everything
again
um
I think to me the you know many of the
points have been made the
and this application this this site has
been
destined for development for quite a
long time
and much as we've heard is quite good
the thing that really really concerns me
is
the committee is for a long time wish to
improve the environmental standard of
building
to get towards the sort of standards
that the Scandinavians have been
achieving for 30 years
and we were either hoping that the new
versions of the building regulations
would lead us that way
we've endlessly been told there were
constraints otherwise on our powers but
asking Builders to willingly comply with
the government's latest guidelines does
not seem to be a bad thing to be doing
and he's therefore concerned to find
mind your developers seeking to stick as
long as they possibly can to the 2013
regulations
it's
2022 now the 2021 rigs have been out for
a considerable period they're even in
force now as I understand
perhaps not totally enforced until next
year
but to be continuing to build houses to
an inadequate standard
to say You from One amounts to minor
construction costs seems pointless
seems to risk the environment and seems
to risk the you know future Prosperity
perhaps of the occupants
so you know I I personally would be
happy to see us approving something that
met 2021 regulations
um and that incorporated lower in a low
carbon heat sources
and it's just difficult to see why that
is so
such a problem I recognize that the
providing the occupants the ability to
pay extra for
the ability to not retrofit their house
in a few years time it is a move forward
that's quite clear
my concern perhaps would be that
when a major Builder
a national company buys a 250 air pumps
for this
installation it would get that at a much
better price than some Port ever will
when he get buys one to to refit his
house or or even the price that he pays
up front will be dramatically more
so
I'm not happy particularly with this at
the moment I shall spend a bit longer
thinking whether we should
whether we should approve it or not
thank you Philip you want to come in
thank you I'm not sure whether this is
the right time there's probably never a
good time for me to chip in on these
things
um I wanted to pick up on a couple of
points just to hopefully assist debate
and we go about the design aspects of it
perhaps we can start Castle even talked
about the cycling links to this and I
don't know Brad could we get the planner
which
um
gives us something town so we can just
get a sense of perspective
um
so um if I could
pull Catherine into this conversation as
well
um as members will be aware here we had
a look at Ash's farm and creating a
route which would lead into
stone Market through Ash's farm and
across the mongino road connection to
the north of the station
um Catherine can I just pull you in on
on how the other connections at work
thank you Phil so yes in an Ideal World
there would be a more direct route from
the site to the station and but as
highways have said there are limitations
there on the physical space required to
fit in a cycle route
we can see that there are two
Alternatives
um but they aren't as Direct
in the district council's local cycling
and walking infrastructure plan we have
identified a desire line that sort of
cuts across and a site that we're
looking at today which is actually part
of a wider connectivity ambition between
Stone Market and old Newton
um
but
in terms of being able to advocate for
you know highways to to review and
closer look at a potential for a more
direct link to the station area
if there were people living there we can
adjust the sort of the way our Elsie
whip schemes were prioritized and
because you know we'd have a higher
population number to to justify you know
further investigation into that into
getting a better more direct route there
thank you German if I can keep going
whilst I've got the momentum there was a
there was a follow-on point around
um the scale of the three-story flat
building and uh privacy as well so
perhaps Brad if we can go to what the
design brief
um an unconscious design brief
if we if we can get to that
as as I think it's been discussed
earlier the the
salmon peach colored rather than the
sand colored areas the sand peach ones
are on this shown as being higher
density rather than lower density so
there is obviously you know a measure of
difference but this is a concept and
well
an absolute so clearly there was some
anticipation of higher density which
inevitably is possibly going to mean
taller buildings
um and you know the end result with that
plan memory was that the concept
and this may go back to councilor Fields
point at the outset the concept was to I
think allow across zones two and three
for the order of 272 dwellings and I
think this is an application for 258 so
there was a recognition that density
would have to go up against the
allocation
um so to that degree we're not
completely consistent with the concept
plan in the location of that building
but nonetheless it is a building which
serves a purpose and then in terms of
that privacy question Brad if we can go
back to the layout plan
um and if you can just highlight where
we've got the three-story building there
and then we've got some dwellings on the
other side of the roundabout
in terms of technical standards
the Suffolk design guide which some of
you will recall the Vintage required and
this is a fairly standard figure from
most design Guides of the of the era 35
meters of Separation Distance by privacy
uh I'm told that we are probably of the
order of about 80 meters separation here
and certainly we are in excess of 35
meters separation at the front of these
buildings over the roundabout and there
are dwellings to the east of the
roundabout which are underneath the kind
of banner on the right side of this
slide so you haven't got that full
picture but literally the the the
dimension
um from north to south across there is
of the order of about 80 meters and well
in excess of 35 meters so I'm
there may be a perception of privacy
loss I think the reality is that most
standards would probably act knowledge
that privacy diminishes once you reach
that 35 meter point so I think that's
perhaps more perception than reality
um so so in Broad terms it will be that
this is not a low density scheme I think
there are reasons why it is the way it
is the design brief has been in the
public domain for some considerable
period of time and albeit that we do not
have a perfect active travel solution
here I think together with your work on
Ash's Farm we have something which
contributes to the options for people
looking to cycle into stone marking and
I think the moment I'll leave it there
champ thank you very much okay so I'll
go next oh do you want to go first and
I'll come after you
next year
um
I was in the original committee and you
know we picked up the Four Points we
asked
um the applicants to look at the street
store unit I think some useful work's
been done there and I think that has
improved so thank you for that
triple parking Still Remains it's always
disappointing and we've got additional
visitor spaces
possibly need a name change there
because most of these states the visitor
spaces are taken up by the residents
anyway so
disappointing but we move forward tuken
Crossing is in the right place
so for me it comes back to
the air source heat pumps and the
problems there I'm not sure we've
achieved too much in the original
offering 30 of the houses would have had
air sorts of heat pumps
there would have been a choice for the
residents which is I think what we need
at this stage
now they can have air source heat pumps
but they pay for the costs
that's going to be more expensive for
them I would have thought if you're
buying 30 percent of the house worth of
air source heat pumps that you can get
the order in early with long leading
times you've got buying power there if I
March in and want to buy a house and
want an air source heat pump it's got to
be done I would have thought on a
shorter time scale in smaller numbers so
the costs are going to go up
PV panels that is a positive but whether
the balance
outweighs the change I don't know
and forgive me if I'm wrong but
I believe we still haven't had a final
comment from the sustainability officer
if this is the Crux of the issue
should we be making a decision without
that officer having the ability or the
opportunity to finally comment
we certainly wouldn't move forward if we
hadn't had highways comment on the
scheme
I don't want to kick it into the long
grass but I'm I don't feel
that I'm equipped
to make the decision on whether the
balance of the sustainability issues is
is enough to turn this down without
professional bot
thank you very much okay my comments
then we'll bring I know Council Hunters
wants to come back again so um I I think
I just want to Echo the car the comments
that I've heard from Council event
Castle mayor and others um you know
Crest Nicholson is a large National
house Builder and it's really
disappointing that someone of that size
has chosen not to engage with the local
community not to engage with the Town
Council and we were really clear in our
last meeting what we wanted none of us
had any doubt uh we we you only need to
look at previous cases that have come
before us this committee you know and we
want what's best for our residents and
for mid-suffolk and what's before us is
not what's best for Mid Suffolk or our
residence is what's best for Crest
Nicholson
uh no doubt but not best for our
residents now that proposes a dilemma
because we here have to make a decision
based on planning reasons and what we
try and do is reach a position where we
can work together for what's best for
mid-suffolk in this case we haven't got
what's best for mid-suffolk but we've
got limited reasons to turn it down on
planning reasons which is the only
reasons we can't turn something down on
Triple parking same again yes
congratulations you are just over the
limit you have achieved more than you
need to but actually most developers
come in here and get rid of all their
triple parking and that's what we're
kind of used to so yes you have done bit
more than you need to you meet the
criteria you've ticked the box but again
it's not right for our residents it
doesn't work we've I've been to your
Estates we've been to other Estates
people Park on Pavements it's
is the nature of the Beast so yes you
know again we can't turn that down on
planning reasons but again it's an issue
on many of the other things we have now
got to a position where I think we're
all pretty happy and it's a real shame
that we can't actually be supportive and
say Well done you've listened we've
adapted we're flexible so I don't want
to support this at all if I'm honest I
can't I think it's poorly conceived I
think it's not right for our residents
and I don't think it's right that we
approve this today but on planning
Reasons I'm really struggling to find
reasons to turn it down unless we can
think of some reasons but on planning
reasons we're struggling so it's going
to be one of those items that the
committee is going to vote with a heavy
heart have to make a decision when we
all know this is not what's best for
mid-suffolk and that is what is so
disappointing to me today
so next up was cancer Humphries Mr thank
you uh yeah dilemma it is
um so just like to ask a question please
Mr Isabel so the sustainability officer
report would that change anything if we
had it
and uh cancer Council have resign
um I think I described earlier that
um we could uh you could issue a
delegation that subject to the full
receipt of the sap calculations which is
what the sustainability officer wants
and to uh the satisfaction of the
planning Authority for all the
permutations of heating Appliance and
provisional photo
voltaic to be given to us we can make
that a conditional requirement
prior to actually granting and planning
Mission and proceeding with this and if
we don't get that to a satisfactory uh
extent we will bring the application
back to you for further instructions but
from my perspective you can seek to
achieve that through a delegation that
we will then go to Crest to get the
information which is unclear absent
confusing that the sustainability
officer does not have and to use that to
ensure that we secure the optimum
Arrangement which I think is what he
talks of for carbon reduction
um and you know clearly that would seem
to me to be the first stage of a
delegation I don't know in a planning
sense because there is not a specific
policy around the particular content
that you have access heat pumps PV
whatever I I think that gives you as a
committee the information that this can
be managed with the information being
provided and then that to be required by
conditions so that the scheme is
delivered in that way and only once that
is done
the planning permission get issued now
there's all sorts of other things that
would have to happen as you know but
that way you have confidence
that that information is before the
planning Authority and that if he's not
in a satisfactory format the application
comes back before you for further
dissemination
thank you it's clear and it does help
definitely
um
is dilemma and the chairman made a
really valid point and the only
important point I think that matters can
you refuse or accept this under planning
regulations
unfortunately the plan regulations on
the regulations we've all got desires
we've all got once we've all got needs
we'll see the future want to save the
planet but unfortunately and uh and I
agree with you such a large company I
think you could do more personally I
really do and maybe you need to think
about the future but that's outside of
this you're a business you run the
business in accordance with regulations
for all the reasons that you run the
business I get that but that's not for
us to say yes or no or it's bad or it's
good are we all have our own opinions so
we have to look at this under planning
regulations the current planning
regulations because that's all we have
to do and just a further question on
that please Mr Isabel so 2013
regulations is what this is under
legal the 2021 regulations that
councilor Fields spoke about
where does that sit in all of this
uh I'm I'm not in a position to answer
your question chairman I can't give you
an answer to that
so that gives me a bigger dilemma now
because I'm really not sure whether it
fits in with the regulations fully or
not and I'd need some advice on that I
think before I I am going to move to a
recommendation I think because we need
to get this going but I need that
information otherwise surely I can't
really be sure what I'm really voting on
so Jim if I can clarify I mean without
checking with building control
colleagues as to what requirements will
apply to what parts of this development
and what rights to follow what standards
apply I'm not going to try and miss you
know give information to the committee
which is not accurate there is something
there
um you know if you if you wish to
instruct me to ensure that as part of
the delegation that's possible
the regulations have very clear
transition Arrangements in place to
every home that is commences
construction post 15th of June of next
year will have to be to pile 21
regardless of anything that's agreed
so with that in mind
um I would like to move this along and
I'd like to propose approval of the
regulation with some conditions added
please and that's that two delegation
points I'd like to sort of um if you
could think about how you're going to
word that
and also the condition about the
inclusion of the air sourced heat pumps
for the initial build thank you
okay thank you do we have a second there
for that at this stage
no okay
do we want to go keep going to further
debate
yes councilmanson
thank you yes
um perhaps if I could just re-ask the
the question about whether you can get
an m43
um into the um into the ground floor
flat
um as that was a question that we were
going to come back to
and um apart from that I'm I mean I'm
I have been pinning all my hopes from
the from the beginning on Mr Isabel
coming up with a with a condition to
delegate
um to to make sure we would get him what
we wanted oh if we can
um but I would I would add to to that
um that that plea for such a delegation
to to be drafted
um that we bring it back to this
committee to sign it off so we know what
we're getting and we can get that in the
public domain very plainly
on YouTube
um so I'm I'm not I mean I'm not overall
I'm not keen enough to want to Second
this but I'd certainly like to hear if
Mr Isabel thinks he can construct what
he's
he's offered earlier
we're asking you
to Magic something up that will that
will enable air SOS heat pumps to be
throughout but I'm not sure we can do
that I I probably I I'll try and pull
rabbits
um I can offer you some words on a
possible delegation and I can do that in
a second the part m43 I need to be clear
what you were looking to achieve because
the other there is a related point I
think councilman you talked about some
sort of drainage in construction as well
as an added condition
so the part m43 expectation that you
would want us to go away and secure as
an amendment to the design if you want
to do that as a delegation that seems to
me that something you can extract
instruct us to take away that the
question then becomes a question of what
Chris can actually deliver
and if they're unable to deliver it when
we come back and deal with this but if
they do achieve that then
um that becomes a question of are you
content that that is decided outside
this room
so what is it that you want to achieve
there would be my first question and and
yes I have some a form of words for the
rest of this but I wanted to understand
what committee really we're driving it
and I think I understand where councilor
Humphries is
is minded to go I've tried to explain
what I thought were possible but I
wanted to follow up around that and
whilst we were at it and talking about
what might be included you talked
earlier in the debate about surface
water drainage issues during
construction and I'm presuming you want
us to add a condition in relation to so
if it's water drainage details during
that construction phase
yes yeah the last Point first yes
absolutely to put a condition which I
was hoping will becoming a standard
offering on everything
um that we we put that surface water
condition on if if if the agent can't
confirm that they can do an m43 then I'd
be happy to leave that to you to
um haggle with them as best you can
um not bring it back to committee or
anything and then
move on to the um
the big
Point chairman if I can have one minute
just to play with the words and then
come back to committee
I feel done
could we perhaps ask
Chris Nicholson again to just expand on
the the
um
asking asking them to speak in how to
defense or whatever the um
the issue with the 2021 regulations
you're saying they've come into force in
in June but they're in force now they
they have to be implemented in anything
that's produced from June where does the
need for low carbon heat sit in that
that those regulations improve
insulation to a
useful but relatively mean a small
amount when does the low carbon heat
requirement
you know basically I suppose at the
moment air source heat pumps cut in yeah
um I think I can probably answer that
question so the the sort of fabric first
approach is governed by one aspect of
partel of the regulations which is the
fabric Energy Efficiency requirement
that has been uplifted going from the
2013 regulations to the 2021 regulations
in practice the crests you know
specification fabric specification won't
be changed particularly between the the
two regulations we were
sort of 10 to 15 per house type so the
move to 21 doesn't mean a wholesale
change in in building specification in
that respect the low carbon heating
aspect and meeting the carbon targets
there's no requirement for low carbon
heating all you have to do is meet two
other compliance metrics which are a
carbon compliance Target and a primary
energy compliance Target and you're free
to do that through whatever means is is
most appropriate or Prof for that
development whether that's gas or heat
pumps or direct electric heating or
whatever you want to do as long as you
can meet those targets
okay thank you
June next year
so that's the that's a picture of the
current and and the future regulations
okay
um I I want to counsel them
uh next up is councilor Mansell
um I just wanted to um question
um because it looks as if we're heading
towards something that might be some
sort of approval whether there should be
any consideration to councilor Muller's
comment about the wooden play equipment
uh whether that could be or whether
whether that could be changed at this
stage thank you
uh I think the answer is yes that's
that's something we can take away
um and I'll I'll add that would you like
me to read out what I've got so far
chairman so
um I think where I've got to as a
recommendation to you is delegate to the
chief planning officer that subject to
the receipt of full sap calculations to
the satisfaction of the local planning
Authority for all the permutations of
heating Appliance and provision of
photovoltaics so that absolute reduction
uh num so the absolute numbers relating
to the CO2 emissions can be compared and
to the optimum arrangement for carbon
reduction across the scheme is in place
that's the first point B to seek design
amendments at the ground floor Flats in
the flat block to be constructed to part
m43 which I realize is not picking up
counselor Humphrey's point of picks up
counselor
um Masterson's point to that m43
standard to the satisfaction Chief
planning officer to require by condition
that the first purchase to be offers
offered the option to purchase air
source heat pumps and that the PV
content remain as proposed and to add a
condition to require service water
drainage details in relation to the
construction phase I need to add add a
further condition related to play
equipment in remind me
um councilman I think it was in the um
that patch of open space sort of in the
northern middle of the site there's a
play area
um I think I think it's down to be made
of wood and there was a request that
maybe that could be reconsidered
okay thank you chairman
um Jessica your chair if I can just if
there's any conditions just to make sure
that that construction management
includes the um pedestrian and cycleway
um
care for within this construction
management plan
just to make sure that where this where
the when on startling road because the
cycle work the pedestrians go across the
axis for the the construction traffic
will be going through so just to
highlight that within the construction
management plan and have some mitigation
for cyclists and pedestrians to not get
hit by a Tipper truck
um and I think Jeff I may I think we're
getting
slightly
um
kind of focused on your building regs
where actually
the thing that I'm concerned about is
what residents will have to do when
government says we're not having gas
boilers anymore or when they're phasing
those out you can't get there'll be less
people servicing them and all the rest
of it and people have to pay to put new
ones in I think that's the you know
that's thinking the future of what our
residents have to deal with and I think
that's an important point Thank You
chair so I'm looking for a second uh
do I have a second there
councilman happy to Second yes sir
I said I think it's the best we're going
to get
um so yeah on on some okay duration I
will so I'm going to go to the vote
based on it proposed by Council
Humphrey's second bit by councilor mayor
um can we just run through the extra
points you don't need to read through
the whole thing but just I think the
highlights is we've just covered it off
so thank you chairman so so firstly
delegates the chief planning officer to
uh secure full uh sap calculations to
the settings to ensure that we satisfy
your sustainability officer insecure
Optimum or agents for carbon reduction
across the scheme seek design amendments
of the ground floor Flats in the flat
block to part m43 standard to my
satisfaction as a matter of negotiation
to require uh the the first purchase to
be offers the option to purchase the air
source heat pump
opportunity to add a conditional growing
surface order drainage details to be
agreed in relation to construction to
agree details around play equipment as
part of the delivery of those areas the
construction management plan to include
measures to safeguard cyclists using
cycle routes throughout the development
and I think that's I'm not sure if I
call that all chairman was there
anything else that
and the subject to that chairman there
is a section 106 obligation which I
think needs to be removed it's a double
double counting point in relation to
traffic regulation order
um so we need to take that out the
recommendation but subject to that the
rest of the recommendation stands thank
you Jim
yeah my writing saying when air source
heat pumps were in the scheme there was
a requirement for a noise assessment
where will we stand in the future if
residents want to install heat pumps
will they need planning permission given
that some of the site will have heat
pumps from them okay
so chairman if they're buying it and
it's not yet been occupied as a dwelling
it doesn't yet benefit from permitted
development rights so uh at the point of
purchase so you buy and you purchase it
will be something that will need to be a
design submission an arguably if it sits
under a condition then that can be
managed through condition with noise
submissions that go hand in with that
for those units that have it
it
permitted development rights would only
apply once you move into the house
essentially
and then later you need to convert to
air source that's not a problem with
moving an s or seat pump on the
permitted development rights and the
noise it creates
well it effectively underpermitted
developments we as a planning Authority
have no role in that there are
conditions attached to permitted
developers that manage those impacts at
this point if you add an air source heat
pump to a dwelling which is not yet
occupied it doesn't benefit from
permitted development rights we would
effectively look to have that as a
submission under the condition so that
for each unit that has one and we can we
can add this as an element to the
condition that each unit that has an air
source heat pump
we we have that information provided as
part of that as a as a condition
chairman
sorry I'm confused so if I purchase a
house with a gas boiler and five years
later I want to install an air source
heat pump I will need to go for planning
permission
no if you purchase a house and it comes
with a gas boiler and you subsequently
change it you may be able to exercise
committed development rights if okay you
comply with the conditions in the
regulations at this point in relation to
what crests are offering if you want to
include an air source heat pump and you
want to purchase one then that will need
to be an element that we agree to a
specification that will be uncomfortable
does not a noise issue
um thank you chair I just wanted to make
the point that if the minutes can
actually be very clear that we're not
happy with this application so that a
future developer or somebody looking
back at this decision thinks oh yes it's
okay to do gas boilers throughout a site
or whatever but um I just wanted to make
that point here so we could be
absolutely clear with what um this
committee is saying today
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
foreign
you're right John
councilor Mathison would you like me to
take you a vote
please sign in
thank you members chair that's four
votes four and three against therefore
that's carried okay I just want to just
say something I don't think we've ever
had a committee meeting where the
committee has been so hostile towards
the developer uh I you know we are only
doing it because we're interested in the
best for our residents and I think there
is a very strong message today from this
committee that while this meets the
planning guidelines it we did not feel
it really was as good as it can be so
it's nothing against
you as individuals we're just trying to
get what we can for the best for our
residents of mid-suffolk and that is the
purpose of this committee so thank you
for bearing with us today I know it has
been easy for you uh but I think there's
a strong message there for both sides
thank you
I plan to move straight on to the next
item there's a design brief item and
then break after the design brief for
lunch then come back and do the next bit
that's the way unplannaged it so if we
can move people around as quickly as
possible please
okay uh
we need
okay so welcome back everyone so we're
now going to move on to the next item uh
which is uh before us it's the
dc2203093 uh in Clayton and Barham and
this is
um the draft design code
I'm going to hand over to Jasmine who's
going to take us through the item today
and good afternoon
member development for 269 dwellings at
land Northwest of Church Lane Byram this
is an unusual submission before members
today in that it relates to the
requirement of a section 106 obligation
ordinarily this would be considered
underdelegated Authority but as the
reserve matters is for quite a
large-scale development and it
intrinsically links to those Reserve
matters members have been presented with
the submitted design code for
transparency
so in terms of the local context the
site is shown by the Red Dot as you can
see Clayton is to the South and Greg
Blake and moves to the west and the A14
is also to the West there
in terms of the immediate context this
is the breakdown of the parishes so it
is within uh Barham but as you can see
you've got uh Clayton to the South great
blackened him to the West
um the site is within the Clayton and
Byron Ward
in terms of constraints the application
site is shown by the hatched area so
you've got a grade one listed Church to
the east which is shown by the green and
a grade two listed building to the kind
of Southwest
which shown by the orange dot there's
also public right-of-way which is the
green dashed Line running along the
eastern boundary and there are a row of
protected trees and hedgerows along with
southern boundary which is shown by kind
of the green and like peachy color
so the submitted design code has been
created in accordance with national
guidance so specifically that relates to
the National design code
the national design guide
the building for healthy life
and then the outline master plan was an
approved plan on the outline permission
and thus has an influence on this design
code
finally there's been a significant level
of public consultation that's occurred
including extensive discussions with the
parish council and local residents
so the national model design code
outlines what a design code should aim
to do and identifies that well-designed
places draws together character
community and climate
this design code before members today
conforms to the earlier mentioned range
of national guidance it specifically
picks up on character community and
climate as key themes throughout and
everything links back to these kind of
three overarching aims
so in terms of the design code that's
been submitted
the following slides will show you how
the design code is broken down into key
sections which mirror the 10 key
principles which are set out within the
national design guide
these principles then link to three
those kind of three key aspects so
character community and climate
um a full copy of the design code can be
found within the bundle
so in terms of the introductory section
this sets out these key aims and its
purpose and the purpose of the design
code which is to explain how the
proposed development is a suitable
response to the site and its setting and
demonstrate that it can be adequately
accessed by prospective users
moving on we then have the context which
is outlined to enhance the surroundings
secondly they've got the movement
section which ensures the development is
accessible and easy to move around
thinking specifically about permeability
and legibility
Moving On Again you've then got the
nature section setting out enhancements
and ways that it can be optimized
then you've got built form which is to
secure a coherent pattern of development
then on to Identity in terms of creating
an attractive and distinctive place
then outlines how public spaces will be
integrated to be safe social and
inclusive
it ensures that the uses within the
place are varied rich and integrated it
talks about the way spaces are to be
used and how this will be achieved
it guides the creation of homes and
buildings on the site ensuring they are
functional healthy and sustainable
it outlines targets for making efficient
use of resources and ensuring the place
is resilient
it seeks to ensure the development is
made to last specifically through
management plans and participation with
the community talking about lifespan
the outline master plan as I mentioned
earlier is included which sets out the
key parameters including size basic
layout General Landscaping General open
space Arrangements in summary it sets
out a blueprint to inform the subsequent
Reserve matters
the reserve matters will then be
assessed against any kind of agreed
design code
so in terms of what it does it's
aspirational but delivers and guides a
range of elements that are to be
incorporated across the scheme there's a
real emphasis and focus on achieving a
Synergy between Green Space built form
and users
the design code as I mentioned earlier
provides a blueprint to guide the depth
and detail of the final Reserve matters
resulting in a far more polished
cohesive and desirable type of
development
uh it is a lengthy document but in
essence it sets out a vision it provides
a kind of illustrated book with examples
of best practice to apply provides a
reference source and checklist for
certain components specifically relating
to design connectivity and open space
sets out key specifications for example
plants for inclusion quality standards
of materials
ensures that it's harder to dilute the
quality of development in subsequent
applications
outlines how elements will be combined
to create a cohesive space
it cross-references back to those three
key elements so character community and
climate and how each element of those
kind of key sections delivers on these
aspects
and it outlines how the Finnish
development should look and function
recommendation is therefore that the
design code is endorsed by members
thank you for listening thank you very
much okay so uh any questions on the yes
we've got a few hands out councilman
councilman
um thank you thank you for your
presentation
um can I I understand that the
uh area of the application site
um when it was an outline included a
land potentially for a school and that's
towards the Norwich old Norwich Road or
whatever it's called but can you just
explain some of the plans in the design
guide include that sort of trapezoidal
field on the far north east of the plot
which isn't included in the indicative
layout at all
um so what is the status of that
trapezoidal arable field in the
northeastern corner thank you
thank you so
um obviously there are elements that
will just be discussed in the reserve
matters
um submission a lot of this was secured
under the section 106 great and
agreement it's only really the
residential part of land that
um Taylor and P control and and as such
obviously they they need to be providing
a design code that basically links well
to these subsequent Parcels that may
come forward so for example the School
site
um but in terms of what the design code
is actually meant to I suppose address
and cover is specifically the
residential areas within that
landscaping and bits pieces but in terms
of the piece of land I don't know if we
can get up the uh I don't know which
slide it would be sorry
I I'm looking at the actual design guide
and it's on page on page 26 of the
design guide itself that I've downloaded
because I thought I need to look at it
there's a sort of orangey shaded map
which includes the School site I
understand that bit but it actually
squares off the corner and yet all the
other plans have got this field cut out
of it
is it this piece here or is it
trapezoidal piece of land is in the
shaded area on some of the pages in The
Design guide and I just wanted to know
what its status was
this might be a question that's best
placed to ask Taylor wimpy
um if they're kind of in within the kind
of three minutes
so it's cancer maths in there
thank you yes yeah I I mean similar with
councilor Mansell um I mean there's page
306 of the papers which which shows the
the
um the community use site at the bottom
and also the um the potential School
site as well as the red line
um but that doesn't show as Captain Man
so he said the the um the piece to the
Northeast and so that that was something
that I was a bit puzzled about as well
and um the other thing which was was
quite striking to me was that this is in
the Parish of Barham
and we've got we've got
um you know warm warm words of welcome
for the amount of work that's been done
with the parish council but it's
actually the the other Parish Council of
Clayderman Whitten and um so I maybe
we'll have to wait wait for councilor
Whitehead to explain
um how they didn't want to express any
opinion about it I mean I understand
that this this piece of land it abuts
onto the settlement boundary of um
claydon
um but that that's just that remained a
bit of a puzzle to me
um that you know I just kept going back
and forth to say well hang on a minute
that's not the same Parish
um and and it isn't is it so I don't
know what happened there but
uh yes so just to confirm um both Byram
and Clayton Whitton Parish councils were
consulted on the design code and I think
we've only heard back from Clayton and
Whitton Parish Council but everyone has
been actively consulted as part of this
kind of um application uh it might be as
you say the council head might be able
to provide some further Clarity on the
precise nature of the kind of community
involvement and likewise Taylor wimpy
might as well
right I see so you're saying that the
all the all the the thanks and and
welcome for the very good engagement etc
etc from your perspective was was with
both
council's works all councils were
involved but not all chose all chose to
reply didn't come back they didn't come
back and say yes thank you for involving
us
okay
from there
thank you um
this is the first time I've never been
asked to endorse a design code and I'll
put my hand up and say I have no idea
what a good design code should look like
that sort of rings alarm bells in my
mind in that
you also mentioned it as a reference
Pacific on page 347 there's a nice
diagram of cable depths where everything
should be in the ground
if this is a reference and a mistake has
been made in transposing those depths
does this reference supersede the
original document and can the developer
use this as an excuse to do it
to this standard rather than other
standard
I've not had time and I do not have the
knowledge to go through and check all of
the technical specifications mentioned
in this
so if it's going to become a reference
and I'm endorsing it
I'm going to have to say we need to go
away and do a huge amount of work to
make sure it's right
now asking us to sign in gov trust me
it's okay is sort of not something that
I
Keen to do
understood
in terms of the
obviously as I mentioned earlier is an
unusual submission and I believe it's
probably the first one that members will
have heard
um the idea is that it guides subsequent
Reserve matters so it's part of the
section 106 obligation and it had to be
sorted and resolved prior to any
approval of Reserve matters
because in essence uh it guides the key
principles so we're talking about the
principles rather than specific
technical detail
So within the reserve matters submission
you will then have that more specific
detail on where bits and pieces are
going the technical aspects of it
um for example drainage basins and you
know the gradients of them
um so the idea is that it sets out the
guiding principles it's not necessarily
A I don't want to say it's not a binding
document but it it's more of a reference
point as opposed to
what you agree under the design code is
exactly what gets built if that makes
a little bit more sense
I want to come in I can see Gemma and
Phillips hands hovering over the mic so
Gemma do you want to go first
thank you
um yeah I was probably just going to
follow up um probably
it's good there we go
um yeah it's guidance it's gonna be
something it's a material consideration
when we come to reserve matters but I
think in terms of any areas if we were
concerned we would still be looking to
grant that at Reserve matters there
might be a conversation but that we've
got
the appropriate consulties at Reserve
matters who would comment on those
details it's trying to channel the
design layout and spec to similar levels
rather than be out and out specific
so if I may let's take a specific now
um parking guidance we work to the
Suffolk County cabins Council
definitions if they've been misquoted in
this guide
and we're now at Reserve matters
can the developers insist that we stick
with this it goes back to the original
reference does it
[Music]
thank you chairman yes so
um no no if there's if there's a need
for an outbreak of common sense you need
to apply common sense and if it's
misquoted to figure from some of the
document you know you are still this
does not Fetter your discretion you've
still got to make a judgment if the if
the parking spaces it says two meters by
two meters and you know who confident
they're going there you will deal with
that and arguably what you do is you
revise the design code to pick up the
error the point is that it is a it is a
guide which has been through a process
of consideration
in the good old days that I remember
from my youth these things were always
the subject of supplementary planning
document status you will recall in
relation to the application we
previously heard that there was a
question what's the status of the design
brief it is exactly this problem that
what status do you give it because to
make it a supplementary planning
document you have to go through a
process a formal process of consultation
for particular periods and and if you
look on the adopted documents on
midsummer's websites for there are
various design codes design briefs call
them what you will around stone Market
which have been endorsed by The District
Council through the planning committee
as a way of getting status to it which
says we know it's not a binding planning
policy but it is a guidance document
that
gives you you know a very clear steer
about what is expected it is not a
Fetter to your hands there will always
be a discretion that you apply and and
you are not technical expert no
disrespect
your offices are there to help you with
the way these documents work and we put
this to you for endorsement
as we have done with others because it's
the it's the kind of wording that means
it's not adoption because it can be
adopted it hasn't gone to the
consultation process so it's it's a form
of words that gets recognition
to a level that means something for
everybody
Humphries
thank you Mr two questions really what
one is sort of to you but also
councilman I didn't understand your
question about the area
is it that there's nothing happening
there or
well it's just in the design guide it
includes that square of roughly square
piece of land on on the early pages of
the design guide and then they just
disappear and I'm not sure whether they
are
I think they may have been in part of
the outline planning permission
um because I vaguely remember that from
some time ago
I I'm sorry I'm on the design guide I
don't know about the actual presentation
to win let's hold it back until John
comes in with his time to speak I was
going to say I think it's the
archaeological sensitive area that
that's what I'm not building there
according to this other map but
um the other question I've got is
um it's words really I'm not a legal
expert by any means but I know there's
one in the room
um by calling it code it doesn't become
a guide
in my mind because a code is like a code
of conduct where you can actually be
actually
kodakon that says this that's a breach
of whereas a guide is this is what you
might want to think about doing because
it's a really good best practice so I'm
I'm challenging you words really
thank you
uh thank you I think in the mppf I'm
looking to uh Phil but
um I think in the mppf that it does
specifically mention codes I think in
terms of its actual use in in I suppose
as a reference point for the subsequent
Reserve matters that is what it is
intended to do I think the words are
probably used a little bit
interchangeably but I would
so I've actually got the definition from
the mppf so definition of a design code
is a set of Illustrated design
requirements that provide specific
detail parameters for the physical
development of a site or area graphic
and written components of the code
should build upon a design and vision
such as a master plan or other design
and development framework for a site or
error does that help a little
thank you it does which asks the other
question which is pretty much what
councilman was saying that
um if that's the case having listened to
your definition of that word
um that actually gives it some bite for
a developer and that I think was your
concern the fact that if it gives it
bite they're going to use it to their
advantage and we'd be hard pushed to
fight against it if we needed to and
that's why I want that definition really
tied down as to what this is is it a
code that they can apply or is it a
guide
even though I've heard your definition
well we can't change the wording of the
mppf uh no we can't when we've got
guidance from it yeah that's that's a
fair point but therefore should there be
some guidance within I don't care what
you call it to be honest with you but
should there be some guidance within
your code that says what it's actually
the the bite it's got for a developer so
we've got some understanding what it
really does
so I suppose just just coming back in
terms of it's relevance and how much
obviously it's a not a binding document
and in terms of the reserve matters you
may well wish to still you know it's up
to members if you want to approve refuse
those it I think the the key point is it
sets out the key areas that it's looking
to really I suppose build on as Gemma
said in terms of parameters
um so for example the Landscaping
so it will set out you know where and
how those public open spaces are to be
delivered it may well be that in those
Reserve matters that then come forward
members may decide that actually it
doesn't go far enough in terms of
achieving those aims it's not specific
enough
the in in the it is a section 106
obligation so it's not the reserve
matters so you're not you know in terms
of if members would then approve the
reserve matters
that is what gets built on the ground
so it's it's more of a
without saying it's I understand the
kind of confusion between guidance and
and code but it effectively is a
reference point so you so we must never
forget the actual planning application
itself will override the design code yes
yeah
right yes um I've still got a lot of
people who've want to speak so I've got
cancer field Council Madison and then
I'll come back to councilman there
thank you a couple of things one when I
declared my
the fact that this is about two miles
from my house I think so I can see this
site so I did forget to point out that I
used to be County councilor for this
area so I have been
a witness to some of the early
discussions
um
it's like to make sure that people
understand that the question really here
is slightly strange with a design guy
bum could understand the purpose if
there were a number of Builders but
there appears to be only one but
nevertheless it does know great harm I
guess and there's a lot of admiration
expressed for Tyler wimpy in here the um
the point I really wanted to discover
was more or less what we've been
covering in a bit with previous
application there is a page 405
illustrates
the buildings that the build standard
Taylor wimpy expect to
apply and there's their current build
standard and all that's on the previous
page and then there's 2022 2025 20
there's something there's a
another one which I'm not quite sure
what that is
um but but the point is that the things
like ground Source heat pumps are
defined as 2025.
just want to make sure you know should
we be agreeing this with things that the
committee clearly wants to see
implemented now if this is a guide for
for the developer I think the developers
actually said he's prepared to put that
in now
once slightly worried about having
agreeing a guide which says something
different
because we agreed I'll be agreeing are
they are they providing the 2025
standard now or 2022 plus heat pumps
just want to make sure that agreeing
this doesn't
later judgment I think can you pick up
on that and Philip I don't know do you
want to pick up bearing in mind the
conversation we've just had in the
previous application
Gemma
um sorry um so I'm just having a more
detailed read I think the
details provided are based on the
regulations that we've got at the moment
and are coming up and I think reading is
that Taylor MP are committing
um to provide those ahead of Regulation
where possible
um and you know looking at the very
bottom of page 405 that it's further
detailed and established as part of the
reserve matters application so it if
that's reassurance they are looking to
do things ahead of time which I think is
that follows what I had added this
morning but that it will then follow the
detail through the reserve matters so it
doesn't
have those implications I don't think
there's a
Jasmine if you've got more but yes so to
just just expand on that and I think
it's important to note that this this
design code would be a material planning
consideration in the consideration of
Reserve matters
um it sets out expectations it doesn't
give members any kind of
um I suppose whilst it sets out those
expectations it is more about stopping
the dilution of quality rather than
exceeding and I think you'll kind of see
I don't know if members have
um had a chance to kind of review the
reservatives in in great depth but in
kind of a the reserve matters that have
been submitted
um they are looking to do 100 airsource
heat pumps
so whilst whilst there is an element of
it's uh I think the point is that that
we want to see we want to see it we're
delighted I'm sure that I don't want to
speak to the committee but obviously
it's you know to see 100 that's great
but in the design guide it's it's sort
of talking about timelines that aren't
within what we would ideally like to
achieve yes and I think like Gemma has
kind of touched on it has to be based on
current regulations so it doesn't it
doesn't stop them going above and beyond
it
because we can't make the design guide
ahead of current regulations
I think it would be
he's not a mandatory document you have
to comply with you just said that so you
could thought the design guide could
incorporate our Ambitions and then a
developer could say we don't have to go
that far because of regulations don't
demand it
we'll leave you to ponder that because
it is a good point and and
you can take it out of the way
one consideration uh cancer maths and
you were next yeah the um you know I I
particularly already got open these same
Pages Council field of foreign
four and five
um and um
yes my reading of it was that we got
these these um dates uh going you know
going forward into the future because
this is quite a big application
and and it's going to take a few years
to build out and and therefore the this
is how we will be meeting the changing
regulations
um and incidentally I did want to say on
the previous application as well I did
have a conversation with the building
control manager to understand how it
would actually abide precisely and what
he said was that we will house by house
if the if the foundations are in under
current regulations then that's what
we're apply into for building out that
house
if you haven't started the foundations
then
on the on the due date in June 23 then
it will have to be the new regulations
that's the minimum that has to be met
but I was yeah that's what I was
assuming this is what these things are
doing and I did notice in reading them a
couple of points that the 20
10.15 this is all on page 404
paragraph 15 16 17. these it seems to me
these are already things that are all
the obligations anyway and I also noted
that 10.21 seemed to repeat 10 15 anyway
uh which seemed a bit um a bit you know
as if someone a bit too much cut and
paste going on somewhere really
um yeah and I finished job writing up
that um yes what we actually need is is
part new part L delivered now which
sort of insane the small
but yeah okay
to some extent but you know as we
gradually kind of understanding what
it's doing
for us and and it seems good we are in
it's quite ready yeah so we're going to
be here all day
questions only precise questions we
don't need to hear about what other we
need to just stop people saying someone
has already said the point I want to say
because the more we say that belong to
the meeting Council mayor
chair um
I know there's a D's and perhaps I've
missed something
um 64 pages of fun why was it included
do I missed something
4 and 16 416 straight after the design
code is that part of the design code or
so that's all it is section 106 on the
um outline yeah so I think um it was
included because there's various points
secured under it to secure the design
code so it was sort of putting out the
background of
is required in this way yeah
a little time to reach 64 pages
I enjoyed it thank you I appreciate it
as a background paper rather than a
officer report
thanks
we have picked up separately around the
papers and the volume and the 26 hours
you would need to read this entire
bundle
okay
um anything else before we're going to
move on we'll move on okay so next up um
so thank you for the presentation next
we move on to
so um
we haven't got any public speakers we
haven't got Parish Council of director
or supporter we now go to the agent Mark
Chapman from Taylor wimpy and I know
we've got James Bailey and Andrew right
here for questions as well over to you
in three minutes please
thank you chair good afternoon members
my name is Mark Chapman I'm the
technical and planning director for
Taylor wimpy East Anglia I've got Andrew
Wright one of our senior technical
managers here with us and James Bailey
who's a planning console lead planning
consultant on this project between us
hopefully we can answer any of the
questions you've got and obviously pick
up the ones that you've already
mentioned today
so we're here to initially discuss the
design code for the site which is the
result of many months of positive
collaboration with both your officers
and key stakeholders in the local
community as well as numerous
pre-application discussions with
officers the key elements of the
documents have also been discussed with
the local community by both in person
and online workshops to the submission
the brief of the design code is clearly
set out in the section 106 agreement and
looks to set out options and principles
to create a better place to live through
good design reduction energy use and
promotion of sustainable methods of
travel
the document is structured around the
national design guide and the national
model design code which together provide
detail guidance on promoting beautiful
design based around 10 key
characteristics which are categorized as
climate character and community
the site benefits from an outline
planning consent which includes a
prescriptive design access statement
master plan and Suite of parameter plans
which provided a good foundation from
which
the design code is looking to create
strong sense of place which will sit
well within the site's existing context
and importantly moves this growing
Community towards a more sustainable
future it also aims to bridge the gap
between an outline planning permission
and a reserve matter so it feels in some
of the detail between those
architecturally four character areas are
being proposed and three which seek a
village contemporary theme to complement
some of the more recent self-built
properties surrounding the development
the fourth representing a purely
traditional vernacular due to the close
proximity of Samaria and Saint Peter's
Church to the northeast of the site
importantly all of the character areas
seek to utilize the best of the local
vernacular and the code clearly guides
building forms use of materials tones
those sorts of things
landscape character areas closely follow
the architectural counterparts and look
to reinforce each architectural area
with its own set of landscape rules and
planting pallets further guiding
principles are set out for the detailing
of play spaces and sustainable drainage
features
being a landscape-led scheme planting
pallets are geared towards improvements
for biodiversity net gain through native
and more drought tolerant species
Furthermore with the desire to reduce
the development's carbon footprint
further living green screen to proposed
throughout to provide private defensible
boundaries to all new homes fronting the
public realm these are being championed
over traditional brick treatments such
as brick walls due to the lower carbon
footprint
sustainable drainage features have been
discussed at length and are due to the
to be multifunctional publicly
accessible spaces of high ecological
value the main spine Road dissecting the
development will have swales on each
side throughout its length all of which
will help with the cooling effect in
warmer drier periods we'll need the last
sentence please okay uh well in
conclusion design code sets out a clear
strategy for delivering a sustainable
development that sits sympathetically
with its immediate surroundings it also
seeks to provide a strong vibrant and
healthy Community addresses climate
change and looks to protect the and
enhance the Natural Built and historic
environment and obviously happy to
answer any questions you may have thanks
very much okay questions
we start at the back cancer even the
councilman
um thank you very much chair thank you
for that
um firstly very simple question the
green screens what plants are going to
be in the green screens and secondly
um
the housing site it's housing part of
the guide refers to that's reflecting a
or having a distinctive character and
good architectural quality and I'm not
clear from it how that's how that is
um
representing or reflecting the historic
environment particularly the church I
mean what is it in this scheme that you
would walk into and think oh I'm closer
to work you know ancient Monument well
it's not speaking English but the church
you know and this this
development says
what to me so I've just wondered if you
could elaborate please on um what you
mean by distinctive character and good
architecture quality thank you
um so yeah so the green screens
um this is something that we have tried
before but um and we've made some
improvements recently so it's
effectively an ivy and it's pre-grown in
a trough against uh like a mesh a mesh
fence to give it some rigidity because
obviously we don't want to put something
up that the pet dog could get out of
your back Garden
um and effectively what we're trying to
do is replace brick walls because
obviously for the bricks you need to
fire the bricks and the Kilns and then
you've got Transportation so there's a
in terms of the character Andrew Truman
I'm sorry just pick up the second point
just in relation to uh within the design
code there's four distinct character
areas I think Mark articulated that in
his opening comments
um with specific comments around the
vernacular for the more traditional it's
it's more reflective of the Suffolk
vernacular and in respectful of the
proximity to the church and the
immediate surrounding Village areas so
it's not it won't have direct parallels
with the church itself of course but it
is respectful of being the Suffolk
vernacular whilst the the rest of the
development has more contemporary feel
about it but some of the key differences
is more selected around not just
materiality but also the boundary
treatment
explained a lot of that is led by a very
much green credentials so looking around
what we can do with those green screens
Etc
um so just to confirm by distinctive
character you mean Suffolk you don't
mean Barham or Clayton yeah that were
suffered more holistically but yeah more
specific to taking the veracular from
the local area so Barra and Clayton
okay
can I try and rethread my question again
um now I've found the relevant page
number it's it's page at 241 on our
papers
um has a drawing of the outline
um permission addictive plan and the
revenue says in our additional Meadow
yeah I know it says additional Meadow
but it it is well it's a meadow but
you've done the landscaping for other
parts of open space so is that
additional Meadow Orange area not owned
by not taken on by Taylor wimpy which is
why it's not mentioned anywhere else
uh yeah that that's right so so this
site has an outline planning permission
Taylor wimpy has just secured the
housing element so so things like the
the school
um the community use and the Meadowland
are being brought forward by the
original sort of vendors and the
promoters now there's legal contracts in
place to make sure that they bring those
forward in line with the section 106. um
but they were particularly Keen to make
sure that they were directly having
those conversations with your officers
so it's not in our control
so they will have to come forward
uh yes it is part of the section 106 I
think I've just found I think it was
prior to uh
implement the meadow prior to occupation
of the 100th dwelling
uh councilman
yeah thank you um chimneys
I noticed that within it you talk about
chimneys on certain parts
of
buildings
are these false chimneys or are we
talking about um fireplaces as well I
may have missed it and I'm sorry if I
did uh so so they would be false
chimneys they we don't put in
um fully working flu chimneys tight
slightly ties in with a lot of the
conversation today with building
regulations air tightness is a big thing
if you're going to move to air source um
so no they are so the question that
always generation Archimedes the roof
has a 50-year guarantee and the chimney
has a 10-year guarantee by putting the
chimney in you are actually degrading
the property and making potentially the
residents increased costs
um no I mean the guaranteed
is part of the roof so in terms of uh
again chimney has the same guarantee as
the room yes yeah it's all part of the
same structure yeah and I haven't got a
problem thank you
okay uh any other questions we'll move
on uh cancer field then we'll move on
after you
sort of return to my question you you
have um in this guide we have uh your
current build standard uh 2020 to 2025
uh and uh
nature interventions by 2023. I just
wonder which one of those
what Murray should really take note of
are you intending to build to one of
them in your uh can one assume it's the
2022 standard or what
not yet so which one of the group and
and I'll just address the point because
the wider point about the the design
code is because design code is there to
set out the options and say you could do
anything between X and and Y so in the
reserve matters we've included the
detail about what that and what that
says is is 100 air source heat pumps
where if um if we proceed today then
construction will start June next year
so it will straight straight away been
on to the the latest building
regulations
um but obviously the Asus heat pumps
will be on top of that and that in
increases the or sorry should I say
reduces the CO2 use of these by about 60
by combining new building regulations
with air source heat pumps
okay thank you
okay so we're going to move on now to
the ward member uh councilor John
Whitehead over to you
thank you chairman
I'm looking forward to hearing the
committee's debate on this extensive
design code
I will speak more regarding this site
when the committee moves on to discuss
the connected application
2203231 next on the agenda so for now
I'd just like to take the opportunity to
advise the committee that as someone who
attended the Village Hall face-to-face
Workshop referenced in the report
can confirm that in my opinion Taylor
wimpy and its advisors
undertook a very thorough consultation
with the public
the meeting was not a drop-in event
that instead was a two-hour long event
that took residents and several Clayton
Parish councilors methodically through
the various aspects
um my understanding as well is that the
bar and Parish Council has requested
their own separate meeting with Taylor
wimpy and that this took place
at the public meeting Taylor wimpy were
very open and genuine in taking feedback
from the community and as is made clear
in the report they made a number of
Welcome changes so to be clear it was
not a tick spot exercise at all I feel
that several important significant
improvements came out of the
consultation
so in conclusion I welcome this
extensive design code and commend the
level of detail produced by the
applicant in consultation with the
members sorry in consultation with the
officers thank you
good thank you very much any questions
no okay so it's over to us to discuss
debate and come to a conclusion yet
custom will you want to go first
um thank you very much I think what
we've learned from this particular
application is the thought that Taylor
Wimpy have done to actually liaise with
both parish councils and thank you very
much for doing that that's very very
welcome
um I think it's an excellent design
guide and I would be happily move
approval on this one chair thank you
a second
cancer field you want to go
I shouldn't say I agree with what's been
said before
um the um it's a good design guide it
covers uh uh a whole range of the issues
that uh we often need to address in the
concern locally people I think it's a
good document particularly with the um
the decision which is actually in the
planning
application obviously but the decision
to incorporate
Essex pumps with the the
2022 design standards is a good one so
I'm more than happy to Second this
is
to speak
no so we'll go to the vote then
okay thank you chair members we'll now
start that vote for you
okay it should now be in progress
thank you members that's
seven votes for chair as councilor
Humphreys has left that is unanimous
thank you thank you very much for that
and what I propose we do how long do we
want for lunch 30 is 30 minutes or 45
half an azerite won't give you
indigestion okay so we'll meet back here
at quarter to two uh and kick off then
and just for members of the public
there's a canteen on the ground floor
you're more than welcome to grab a
sandwich down there
um and meet you back here thank you very
much
okay good afternoon welcome back
everyone so we'll move straight on to
the next item which is
dc2203231 uh gender item 7c again
including them back over to Jasmine
again
thank you
thank you chair so this is the reserve
Masters application for 269 dwellings at
land Northwest of Church Lane Byron the
reserve matters are appearance scale
layout and Landscaping it also seeks to
discharge conditions pursuant to the
outline permission
so there are four conditions which
relate to surface water drainage Market
housing mix and a noise survey
this Reserve mata's submission has been
designed around the design code that has
just been presented to members and the
design code is an integral element of
the detail
so just to remind members this is the
site shown in red
and again quickly just to run through
the key constraints so you've got the
grade two listed building to the West uh
grade two grade one listed sorry Church
to the east a public right-of-way to the
East and protected trees and hedgerows
to the South
so the access and spine Road were
approved outline so just to show you the
blue dot outlines the road which is
fixed as part of the outline everything
that then comes off of the spine road is
the subject of this application
foreign
the Key Road layout now so firstly we
have the major access road which was as
I say secured outline
then we have a secondary Street
then minor access roads
shared surfaces
and private drives
in terms of connectivity and building
upon and addressing the key vehicular
routes
uh firstly there's a three meter wide
link to the school site
smaller Pathways to the church
cycle Crossing points on the spine road
with cycle markings
a pedestrian cycle
um Crossing in the center which connects
to
the green corridors and Village Green
then you've got The Pedestrian links to
adjacent highways
Countryside links
green corridors
links to the park and the public open
space to the east there
community site link
and vehicular links
and then finally a three meter wide
cycleway
all of these are set within a wider
landscape setting supporting active
travel and Wildlife
so in terms of green spaces
first of all the Blue Line shows the
central green Avenue so this contains
swales on either side so kind of working
from the center outwards it kind of goes
road to sway all path trees
then the red circle is a Village Green
acting as a central Hub of open space
which is well overlooked by dwellings
with Pathways notably this Village Green
is included in this RM but wasn't on the
outline
then there are green corridors
and
areas of larger and public open space to
the east and west of the site which
incorporates attenuation basins both of
these are again well overlooked by
dwellings
there are 15 Bungalows proposed some of
which are affordables which are shown in
the orange
these Bungalows act as the interface
between the more urban and rural areas
facing towards the grade one listed
Church
thus reducing kind of potential impact
arising from scale
in terms of the scale where there are
not Bungalows they're all two-story
dwellings they don't include any sort of
Dormers or anything the roofs
the affordable units would be pepper
potted around and are well integrated in
desirable locations as you can see
they're not all just tucked in one
corner
um strategic well the council strategic
housing team are happy with the overall
mix
so the parking provision across the
development is Surplus to parking
guidance
um given by Suffolk County Council a key
approach is the private service drives
which
so as you can see they provide adequate
space to accommodate informal additional
parking spaces within the driveways so
not blocking obviously minimizing
conflict and congestion along the spine
Road
but also offering additional kind of
parking spaces where there might be some
triple parking
so a range of house types Incorporated
across the scheme which will be roadken
down by architectural features materials
orientation and to prevent a uniform
appearance
the apartment
um adopts the appearance of two houses
um and includes again architectural
features such as bay windows
and but they are designed to look like
two houses effectively
um all would have access to bin stores
and cycle stores
so in terms of 3D visualizations just to
run through the key spaces so here we
have the Central Village Green within it
you have the Village Green and then
Pathways within it you've a green link
main Crossing Point
cycleway
then you've got swales
and tree-lined avenues
in terms of so here we have the green
Corridor and so again that kind of leads
into the village Hub and Village Green
rather
then we've got here's a view entering
from Norwich road so looking kind of
northwards
uh in terms of the green screens
proposed they are one form of boundary
treatment these will provide instant
Greenery and will be Evergreen
the green screens come really cultivated
for easy installation as shown by the
right hand image all have mesh inside
here are the locations for the green
screens as you can see they are
scattered around the development and
they are a bit of a trial on the site so
a number of management measures and
assurances are proposed including a
management a management plan for five
years covering the public realm side the
developer is also looking at covenants
um on the sale of the units to ensure
they cannot be ripped out equally if
they die within a number of years
they'll be replaced by new ones or
should they kind of die or fail and then
the alternative is not going to be close
ball defensing it will be a 1.8 meter
high brick wall
in terms of structural Landscaping uh so
you've got the Central Avenue with trees
and swales as we've got a scene
green links and green corridors
Wetland area with attenuation basins
a rural Edge
Meadow grassland
Orchard
tree-lined approach towards the church
kind of informal tree belt which is
opposite protected trees on the other
side and to the South
and a boundary hedge along the school
in terms of the public open space to the
east there would be a community Orchard
with public foraging Trail encouraging
wildlife and supporting education which
obviously then links well to the Future
School site
play equipment will offer natural play
incorporating well-being into the
development and again working with the
public realm team
in terms of the drainage basins so three
drainage basins are posed two to the
west and one to the southwest corner and
a post and rail fence would be put
around them which again retains a sense
of openness but is a safety feature
uh floods Suffolk County Council floods
and water are happy with strategy the
Basin is constructed with a one in four
gradient which does mean
worst case scenario if a child was to
fall in
um then they would either be able to
kind of stop on a platform or they would
be able to walk out that's kind of the
idea in terms of keeping that gradient
um then we've got the length
air source heat pumps are proposed to
serve all of the dwellings
um so just linking back to the design
code and those three key characteristics
that we spoke about earlier and the
following three slides outline the key
aspects of the scheme and how they link
back to the to the design code so
firstly these are the measures linking
um within well Incorporated within the
scheme to address the community aspects
secondly a range of climate related
measures are incorporated as well which
mostly spans a range of sustainability
measures
finally we have the character aspects
that are Incorporated which include key
visual aspects
in relation to the discharging
conditions all of the technical
consultants are happy with the details
submitted
an additional condition is recommended
on this Reserve matters to ensure that
the submitted noise survey readings are
those that are actually achieved on site
so the recommendation the first part is
therefore to approve the reserve matters
subject to the conditions outlined
within the report
and secondly to discharge conditions 9
10 and 40 and part discharge condition
48 of the outline permission
thank you very much
thank you very much okay
I'll start off with questions
counciloria first
we'll go
the uh just the noise survey the sort of
the noise from the A14 is fixed I
wondered what that
actually controlling is it the um
to tell who windows were over triple
glazing or whatever
so that's one question what's that
fixing the other thing I I seem to
remember in your in the presentation it
spoke about doctor surgery which I think
is close some time ago
um
they can't obtain any of your staff for
it I may be wrong there but I believe
that's true and you also talk about
there's a lot made of bus routes and
indeed it is quite well served but a
number of the ones that mentioned have
since ceased to function
just wondered if we could make clear
what the actual position is
um yes so I'm not entirely sure in terms
of the
um the GP surgery or the bus rates
obviously a lot of this was dealt with
at the outline stage
um so a lot of it is kind of beyond our
control at this point
in terms of the noise survey I'm just
having a look at what is on the outline
and it talks about it is basically to do
with the impact of noise from the A14
um
and it's to ensure that those internal
noise levels don't go above kind of um I
think it's World Health Organization
standards so it's just basically the the
kind of part discharge element of it is
to ensure that the
um dwellings once built that they kind
of accord with the um survey results
that have been submitted to us now so
it's just making sure that they are
actually achieved rather than just being
told that they're achieved
the math
thank you yeah a couple of couple of um
minor minor questions really
um with with this the green screens
which is you know interesting
um trial Innovation Etc
um
will I have um Hedgehog highways through
them which we've we've come to expect
um going in various directions out of uh
in and out of um back Gardens
um but also I wonder we probably need a
um
an informative so that the household is
understand because the cost of replacing
one of those with the brick brick wall
is going to be pretty significant
actually so it's something on that one
really
um yeah so that's just two questions for
now
uh thank you so in terms of the green
screens and Hedgehog highways and that's
probably something just to ask the the
developer during their three minutes
right and uh in an informative obviously
we can we can add that in and that's not
a problem
thank you councilman
uh thank you chair um I've got a couple
of queries about the acts the roads
um obviously the main spine road is is
already done on the outline but the
secondary roads or whatever they're
called are they going to be adoptable or
adopted or are they all going to be
privately managed
on the plan which I think is on slide 10
the one of the secondary roads looks
like it has a splay onto Church Road is
that actually an access point or is it
an emergency access point
and there is quite a large amount of
public open space alongside this
development
um has that been offered to the parish
or the district council because clearly
it is for the benefit of everybody in
the community not just the residents of
this development
uh thank you so in terms of the
secondary Road um I don't know if this
so is it the the blue line
blue the dark blue line on the when you
look at the plan it looks like there's a
visibility display yes so I believe that
there is to be um a vehicular access
there but you might want to check that
with the developer
um
in terms of adoption again that is
something I might have to come back to
you on I think uh Suffolk County Council
highways have actually mentioned that um
but obviously that would be subject to a
separate consent um I think it's section
38. um so yeah in terms of I can
certainly double check that but it might
be worth asking the developer and and
the public open space as far as I'm
aware
um our public enrollment team have been
quite heavily involved in terms of
obviously looking at the detail of it
um I'm not sure and I would have to
double check how that has been secured
but it would have been under the outline
section 106 so there should be something
in there that talks about if it is to be
offered up
um to the parish or or District Council
within that I would have to double check
that for you
country band
um thank you very much chair
um just with regards to the the play
area
um it says that it's outside of Reserve
matters yet um
in the conditions it's just as an
informative so I'm not quite sure
how that
you know
what what decision we're making whether
you know ultimately they could say well
we're not doing it
A reduced size player or whatever so if
you could just sort of clarify the
position with the play area please and
then secondly on the market housing mix
um condition 40 which I know we're being
asked to discharge says that the housing
should be predominantly two and three
bedroom but yet out of 175 Market homes
only 64 or two and three bedroom and I
don't call that
predominantly
it's less than half so I don't
understand how we can discharge that
when it doesn't even meet anywhere near
condition 40. so if you could just
explain that for me thank you very much
thank you then I might have to come back
to you on the market housing mix
um in terms of having a look at the the
specific condition
um and the play area
um as an informative it is yet we have
recommended it as an informative I would
again have to double check why that has
um
how that has kind of come about it might
be as a result of our public realm team
yeah I mean on page 500 there's a kind
of bit of a discussion about play area
but then it's not clear
to me whether
I mean I'm assuming that that means
there will be play areas in places that
are indicated on the on the layout but
I'm not I'm not 100 clear that's all I'm
you know yes and it does say it does say
that
um
you know the appropriate levels appear
delivered by this development site
outside of the reserve matter submission
so yes so I think what um what has
actually happened just now looking at it
um condition 27 and 28 of the outline
permission requires the full Landscaping
details and which isn't always imposed
on an outline sometimes it is kind of
delayed until the reserve matters
because obviously you're primarily
looking at the Landscaping details and
but as part of that I think the idea is
the reason it's been put on as an
informative is to ensure that as part of
those conditions when they come in to be
formally discharged and it will include
the details of the play equipment so it
is secured
customer thanks so much can you confirm
that um all the roads other than the
private drives will be adopted by the
County Council or offered for adoption
did you did you really I do apologize to
everybody I'll wake up what was the
answer
um yeah the second one then the grease
screens interesting idea it is a trial
um
at what point would liability fall to
the homeowners if the trial were to fail
on a large scale would the homeowners
have to replace the wall or would uh so
I think the idea is that we will have
that management plan in place so for the
first uh five years I think that's
check
um
yes so in terms of so the first five
years
um is basically a management plan
covering the public realm side of the
fence
um or rather the screens
the developer is also looking as I said
to impose covenants on the sale of the
units to ensure that you know they can't
be actually ripped out
um again if the the green screen green
screens die within a number of years
they'll be replaced and I'm not sure as
yet who would be liable for those those
matters and I believe it would be
between the kind of uh the developer and
the homeowner and to kind of obviously
work out the arrangements with that but
that might be a question that's asked
the developer
if we were it's a trial if there was a
large-scale failure and all the screens
failed then it would be a bit rough yes
and I think yeah that's obviously why we
need to get that management plan
agreed as well
so that's been answer thank you
um sorry this is just sort of dawned on
me
um we've got sort of as you say hybrids
um application thing here and we've got
three recommendations
um on page 493
um when do we have to do them all do we
you know are they dependent on one
another can we
um you know prove one and not not the
other two or or what happens if that is
the case
so I think they've been made as one
application and that's why we're
reporting that back to you as one
application uh I think if there were
discharge of conditions that you weren't
happy with I think that might be a
suggested delegation on those aspects
and we could take that away certainly if
there are other matters we perhaps might
need to go through that as members raise
them but possibly some flexibility
House of Food
it's coming really couldn't you control
the green screen issue with permitted
development rights presumably people
currently have
the right to replace those with
fencing as as is normal around any plot
one wonders whether one could control
the I think maybe the replacement with
bricks or whatever in that way so the
idea will be
um that it is kind of notwithstanding
permitted development rights and I would
need to check the outline permission to
see if any permitted development rights
were removed because they're normally
removed on an outline permission if you
were removing them at all
um
obviously this this condition would kind
of be worded in the way that it's
notwithstanding any permit development
rights these green screens are retained
um but obviously if members wanted to to
kind of add some some further
informatives or kind of Direction in
terms of how that condition is worded
then
whatever way you would have most
effective control and I'm sure the
developer and we both want
to travel yeah
the future and uh you know covenants and
things are often notoriously difficult
to enforce
that was one question the other one the
um you're you're controlling in your
recommendation the hundreds of percent
here
air source heat pumps um what about the
insulation level of these buildings and
things like um
uh car charging points which I noticed
you know were in the design yard we
looked at but are they actually required
in this you know are they specified as
so in terms of the the insulation
um that isn't something that I believe
that we have conditioned and I'm not
sure if um Gemma might have some some
ideas on I think that might be slightly
more difficult to control because it's
not actually development in that sense
um the EV charging points I had actually
noted down that might be something that
members wish to include as a an
additional
um condition but I would need to again
check the outline to check that we're
not kind of duplicating conditions
yeah similarly I'm just trying to scroll
through the outline while we have this
conversation just to check on what some
of those conditions are so perhaps if
between us we'll have a look and see
what's already conditioned I would
probably urge caution about conditioning
insulation with the building work
situation I think that would go above
and beyond what we should do
um on that one if there's particular
issues you'd like to raise I'm happy to
think about it further presumably it's
impossible to condition that
regulations
whatever 2023 be applied to deliver
whatever the standard is at the time we
can't condition about that the company
does seem to wish yeah but we can't
really know
thank you okay so I'll move us on so
all right okay yeah
yeah
um does does this condition nine surface
order does that cover this um during
construction problem that I've raised
already earlier
and second question I know this is a an
existing hedge right across this site
and we managed to retain some of that in
in the landscaping or is it all going to
be ripped out and replaced with twigs
massive massive water runoff because it
isn't
there isn't anything in place to deal
with it during construction so yeah so
there is a construct
a constraint terms of the existing
Hedgerow I'm not entirely sure so that
might be something if you look at the
aerial photographs you can see yeah
yeah
okay
so um we don't have the parish council
we don't have an objective sport to go
straight to the applicants and again we
have Mark Chapman James belly and Andrew
Wright here and over two for three
minutes please
uh good afternoon again thank you for
endorsing the design code in the last
item with the outlying consent secured
in January this year and a successfully
endorsed design code this afternoon it's
clear the principle of residential
development has been established on this
site
the fact that we are here this morning
before or this afternoon before you with
a robust and sensitive Reserve matters
application for such a major site within
11 months of the outline application
being approved shows Taylor Wimpy's
commitment to delivering this site for
housing credit must equally go to the
council's officers for providing
constructive feedback and for being
available to ensure that this
application was dealt with in a timely
manner and in such a collaborative
fashion before progressing further it's
also important to note that this site
has been referenced in the council's
draft annual monitoring report and one
will contribute to the council's housing
land Supply in the future
Taylor wimpy submitted this Reserve
matters application for 269 homes public
open space and Associated infrastructure
this includes 94 affordable homes
comprising of 67 affordable rent and 27
shared ownership all of the affordable
homes comply with the nationally
described space standards
this Reserve matters application
includes appearance layout scale and
strategic landscaping and also
series of conditions from the outlying
consent the principles set out in the
now endorsed design code has guided the
scheme and in doing so we've prepared a
layout and design that is complementary
to the immediately surrounding area
ongoing discussions throughout the
application process have also helped
shape the scheme before members today
the proposed dwellings fronting Norwich
Road have been set back from the highway
with sustainable drainage features now
providing a landscape entrance to the
site Bungalows have been purposely
designed to overlook the public open
space being provided to the northeast of
the site this also provides a careful
transition to mitigate the impact of the
setting on Saint Mary's and Saint
Peter's Church
the important green spaces including the
Village Green have been relocated and
enhanced during the application to make
for better connected and usable spaces
specific link into the future Primary
School side to the north has also been
discussed with district and County
Council offices and has been integrated
within the layout Footwear and cycle
paths add to the permeability across the
site sustainable drainage features have
been incorporated into the proposals and
the main spine road is tree-lined as per
the latest requirements of the mpp-f too
many peace sorry green screens are being
Incorporated in certain locations of the
development as a way of providing
instant natural screening for occupants
at the same time this provides
additional biodiversity habitats and
helps to soften the development
the overall aim has been to ensure that
dwellings do not have any adverse impact
on the existing Street Scene or Village
character and that the setting of the
church is respected
to conclude this is a reserve matters
application for a site that benefits
from an existing outlying consent and a
recently endorsed design code Taylor
Wimpy's thoughts bring forward a
well-designed scheme for the site that
incorporates a number of sustainable
features including electric charging
points time is up so last sentence
please as well as other Innovative green
measures
so I'll therefore respectfully request
that members support that officer's
recommendation and approve the
application today and of course happy to
answer any questions
thank you questions
Council Matheson and councilman
um
yeah the the green screens
um does the we see that how they're
being produced we've seen this we've
seen this line now
um do their roots go down through the um
trough into the ground yeah to get oh so
yeah good
um I was hoping that would be the case
and the other one is once again
um given that you've got a nice number
of Bungalows on here
um can we make them compliant m42 and
perhaps a couple of them m43
um I mean that that is a live market
with people that have got money
um I think you know you find it helpful
in your point of view yeah just to
confirm there's six Bungalows on the
scheme which are two M4 standards uh
four of them to M4 part two and two of
them Temple part three yes
of course John we're not expressing any
opinions at this stage
it's only questions for clarity
councilman thank you chair I I would
like to repeat my other questions about
the uh whether the roads are being
adopted or adoptable and what the
whether the there have been any good
negotiations about the public open space
with
um public bodies rather than a
management company
um and I'm also quite intrigued by the
spine Road having these swales on either
side to keep the
pavement cycleway whatever you want to
call it away from the road but clearly
the accesses to the private drives that
serve the dwellings cross it and I I
just want to know if you've used this
scheme in other developments and does it
prevent cars parking on The cycleway
Pedestrian way because it looks like it
ought to but maybe you've got experience
of it thank you yeah yeah no so happy to
take all those so so we mentioned
earlier about the highway adoptability
so yeah the intention is for all the
highways to be adopted there are
obviously private driveways as well but
all the main highways are adopted the
connection that you mentioned onto
Church Lane that is a connection and it
has been agreed with the highway
Authority that's been looked at in terms
of the Swale positions and parking yes
we've done it quite a lot one of the
things that we've done in addition here
through discussion with your officers is
widen some of those private driveways so
the if they want additional parking
that's informal they park on the private
driveway and there's still room for
Neighbors to get to get past
um do you like a couple wear items
public open space Oh public open space
so we haven't got into the detail of who
would be adopting it happy to have a
conversation if Parish Council and
things have got
um have got the resource to manage it uh
what I would say is if it does go
private we don't stop the existing
Community use it so we don't gate it
it's just it's maintained by the
receipts from the from our residents
uh well on the access
um onto Church Road from that secondary
Road there's a cycleway that crosses it
and it looks as if the cycleway's got
priority over the access is that correct
and and my and my reason for asking
about the public open space is because
people who've moved into an estate in my
ward are complaining that other
villagers are using their play area
yeah and and I do understand that
sometimes there's a little bit of
tension if it's privately managed but I
I think that's part of our role is to
explain to people when you move it it is
public open space it's not private open
space for the residents so I do
understand the point but it's
um uh it's unfortunately one of those
things but you're right about the the
cycleway does have priority over that um
over that access
okay no cancel the field
return is going to bound to Eva charging
points for for cars I see they're on the
design guides Etc they're not in the
list of conditions I just wanted to know
exactly what you're providing I think
you implied this then all all dwellings
is that all dwellings with charges or
some of them with so-called passive
charging capability a pair of wires or
or just exactly what I even tested so
we've got the exact numbers are so 197
of the homes have the full 7.3 km
charges
the 72 that don't currently at the
moment now the reason that is Our
intention is to deliver 100 electric
vehicle charging across all of our sites
going forward the reason we haven't
committed to that at this stage is the
the building regulation around it has
this uh statement about where
technically feasible now this
development will take five years to
develop so what's technically feasible
today as we sit in front of you is very
different to what we technically
feasible in a year or two years but
certainly it's Taylor wimby's intention
to wherever possible deliver 100 because
why would we want to sell a product that
someone can't plug their car in in the
future but in in terms of what we've
been able to commit to in the
application it's 197 homes and then the
rest is for us to try and bring forward
as the scheme develops
okay thank you very much right so we
move on to the we have no one here from
the parish council we have no objective
no support sir I said that ready so we
get straight on to John Whitehead as the
board member
uh thank you again chairman
I mentioned earlier that I attended the
face-to-face Workshop held in the
village hall and there it was clear that
many locals are still deeply unhappy
with the principle of a very large
development occurring on this site
clearly with the approval of the outline
hybrid permission that boat has now
sailed and I hope that any residents
watching this I run the live stream or
on catch up we'll understand that the
application and debate today is simply
on the appearance layout scale and
landscaping for this site
obviously as a ward member I understand
that and therefore approach this Reserve
matters application on that basis
it's clear from reading the officer's
report that they are very pleased with
the collaborative approach that
developer has taken in its interactions
with our planning department
on the first reading that enthusiasm may
seem excessive and on third the
considered rereading that enthusiasm
does seem well Justified
details such as the provision of 100 air
source heating throughout the
development
is most welcome
in my previous speech to referrals I
deplored the planting of 269 gas boilers
on this site in place of the
agricultural crops previously planted
there
the green screens trial initiative is
interesting the idea of producing
instant green boundaries is exciting
whether that should be fast growing
invasive Ivy as shown in the
illustration is a matter for the
committee to debate
I welcome the extensive mix of house
sizes from two to five bedrooms with a
good proportion of the market housing
being detached houses and the choice of
locations for the affordable housing has
been well thought through
spine road with its service parking and
wide Boulevard look is most welcome
so I don't intend to say much more I
didn't welcome the principle of
developing on this site I'm still firmly
the opinion it will create traffic
problems and put real pressure on school
spaces
the NHS has now closed the village GP
surgery and only a couple of weeks ago
the need of Market practice announced it
would not take on new patients
so this site will not be suitable for
the ill or in firm so that can be said
of The Wider Village of Barham and
Clayton which is an appalling situation
but clearly not the fault of Minnesota
District Council
but let me conclude on a more positive
note by expressing The View that the
developer in conjunction with our
planning officers have done an
impressive and commendable job on this
Reserve matters application thank you
thank you very much any questions to the
ward member
yes councilman
um thank you chair it's not really for
the ward member because I just wanted to
I had an answer from my question to the
officer about the um
um condition 40. so on page 539 the fact
that that condition says right at the
top of the page submitted out Ice Age
with predominantly two and three bedroom
dwellings and yet um the actual
amount of two and three bedroom
dwellings of the market housing is 64
dwellings out of a total 175 so I just
wondered how we can
what's the definition of predominantly
because that's not predominantly to me
so I just wonder how we've got to that
thank you uh thank you yes I I have got
an answer for you so if uh you read on
in condition 40 it does say submitted
um so uh indicative housing mix
submitted to outline stage with
predominantly two and three bedroom
dwellings unless housing need evidence
indicates otherwise so the housing needs
evidence uh there's obviously most up to
date with our strategic housing team
they have assessed the submitted mix and
they are content that it does meet that
kind of registered need
um obviously this is an outline
permission that does go back
quite a few years so
um yeah that's that when it says unless
housing need evidence indicates
otherwise that's kind of the the key
element of it okay thanks for that we
haven't got that I've got the
information in the papers all I've got
in the papers is strategic housing's
response about affordable housing but
nothing about markets so I you know I
just have to get I appreciate that yep
okay good uh Council Matheson yeah I
sorry chair I realized I forgot to ask
the agent about that hedge across the
middle of the site it's quite important
of course because the biodiversity
benefit is much more if we manage to
retain much of the Hedge than than if we
okay can we get an answer from somebody
yeah
uh yeah so the Hedge is it's actually
it's a bit misleading it doesn't go
through the middle of the housing site
it's actually running up the side
between where the school will be and the
housing but yes it's retained and you've
also got the Church Lane one
satellite there's a hedge across the
middle somewhere is there not
am I not imagining that one sorry about
that if I'm wrong okay I'll give up
thank you okay so members we've had all
the information put before us it's up
for us discuss debate and come to a
conclusion
customer you want to go first uh thank
you very much once again I'd like to
thank the representative Taylor wimpy I
think this is an excellent scheme and
also the comments from the the ward
member I particularly like these green
screens I think that's an excellent idea
but at a point that uh character
Whitehead raised obviously ivy can go
grow quite quickly and it could
potentially get very untidy and
overgrown I presume hopefully the
residents will keep them in trim or a
management company of a management
company is responsible for them but on
the whole I think this is a really
really good application I do like it and
I would I'll be more than happy to
recommend approve your chair
foreign
I I I think I too would like to commend
the applicant and the agent for the
amount of uh Community engagement that
they've done on this particular
application and I think uh it is it is a
good job um and I really think that
having 100 air source heat pumps is is
wonderful and we just wish everyone
could do that
um and it's it's it's great that we've
got adoptable roads large amount of
public open space I would like that to
be kept within the public realm rather
than a a private company if at all
possible
um uh I don't like false chimneys some
of your houses have got false chimneys
um looking through the plans it looks
like there are differences
uh in the design of the affordables with
the market housing but I hope that's not
going to be obvious you know the
materials are probably the same but they
are a slightly different size and um
configuration so they're not tenure
blind properties
um I I'm disappointed in the housing mix
given that we had that condition which
councilor e Byrne has gone on about
um being predominantly small uh two and
three bedroomed homes on the market I
was quite surprised at the ward members
comment that he thought it was great
there were a load of detached
houses for open market
um I I think we do need small houses I'm
quite surprised that there is not a need
for small houses including aborum but we
don't have any evidence to say that that
is the case so we can't really argue
with housing mix because we don't have
the evidence
but most places want a load of small
houses so that does surprise me
um but on the whole I think this is a
good application I think it's been well
thought through
um so yeah I'm uh
um
has councilor Mueller actually made a
proposal we're looking for a second so I
think I I'm happy to Second this
application I think it is a good
application obviously nothing's going to
be perfect and we have to just accept
that in life don't we
okay thank you very much uh next up is
cancer field then Council Mass
uh just to keep up with uh course of
approval
um you know happy with this application
I think pleased to see the
interaction with the local community
particularly as that Community started
off in a fairly negative position so
it's good to see that's moved forward
there are a few things that do concern
me that they're not actually
no Downy in
conditions things like the electric car
charging and perhaps the insulation
thickness in the walls I guess I'm
prepared to accept that the the
developer is is trying to do the right
thing and that even as the economy tanks
over the next year or so it's unlikely
that they will withdraw some of those
facilities so I'm certainly happy to
vote for this
yes thank you I I think yes it's it's
been so refreshing to actually
um rather than battling with the
fundamentals
um just to spend our time on actually
getting some of the detail sorted out
exactly which has been great and you
know I can't help linking that with the
with the good quality engagement that
one one has followed from the other we
which is which is excellent and just on
this housing mix some point I mean the
the Strategic housing team raised no
objection they didn't leap in in support
of all the five-bedroom houses but
um there we are they've not objected so
so we'll go with it won't we
uh say sorry thank you uh well done to
Taylor wimpy for engaging uh with the
community so well uh also it's listening
and bringing forward obviously think
about the environmental impact of the
estate and doing all you can
um I think the green walls are very
interesting I'll be very interested to
see how they survive how they last
um certainly birds love nesting in Ivy
so that's a positive triple parking is
obviously my one of my bug bears but I
think the extra parking place that
you've put in the front of each house
that we saw the pictures actually that's
quite again that's an Innovative
approach and let's see how it works
um but again I think that's addressing
something that we see as a concern so
yeah I'm absolutely happy to support it
and uh commend the um the agent and the
applicant for the work they've done
okay so on that basis we'll go to a vote
it's been proposed by councilman
seconded by councilor Mansell over to
you
are you happy thank you
key
thank you members chair that's seven
votes for don't you
foreign
okay so we're now moving to as I said
application
dc2203423 uh the case officer hello I
think it's your first application before
the committee so welcome thanks for
joining us and we'll hand over to you
thank you
thank you very much chair so um
hopefully this is
going to be slightly shorter than some
of your other previous presentations
this morning
The Proposal is for outline playing
permission
for the erection of one new dwelling a
one and a half story dwelling in
elmswell
so this is an aerial shout showing the
application site
and this is their site location plan you
can see the railway to the north of the
site but
that's right
sorry apologies just bear with me
so this site is within the center of
elmswell highlighted by the pink blob in
the middle of the pink Square the
turquoise boundary is the settlement
boundary of elmsworld Village as defined
by the local plan
therefore because it's within the center
of the settlement as a purely spatial
exercise
the site is considered sustainable
elmswell is a identified as a key
service center within the core strategy
and therefore this proposal Accords with
policy cs1
as the previous
um
slide showed the area subjects this
proposal is a piece of flat grassed land
um and I'm going to outline why us as
officers feel that the site should be
classed as public open space
So within the nppg they Define open
space can take many different forms it
doesn't have to be a recreational
facility with a play area on it
it can be open areas within a
development
and less formal spaces
so this shows a photo of the site quite
clearly showing the flat grass area to
the left of the photograph
so as as part of their submission
elmswell Parish Council have provided a
statement saying they don't believe it
is public open space
they believe the site's amenity value is
diminished because they've erected a no
ball game sign on the land and therefore
there are limited usages
however
we have received
a substantial objection comments from
the local residents which have
highlighted a variety of purposes that
they utilize the site for
this
um
this is actually showing the approved
layout drawing back in 1994 from the
reserved matters application
and although it's incredibly hard to see
on here
um
if I zoom in you can just about see that
the larger of the two areas that are
highlighted in blue are marked as POS
public open space this larger area is uh
at the west of the crown Miller State
and known as the crown Mill play area
and this
is a photograph of the area kindly
provided by councilor Mansell
the smaller area
which is the site subject to this
proposal is also marked as public open
space unfortunately when you zoom in on
this kind of projection it doesn't it is
an obvious
and that's a photograph of the site also
provided by Council and Council
so that's just showing the two of them
again
this is a list of all the different
activities that the local community
residents have said they enjoy the site
for
so they we consider therefore they value
the piece of land and they don't
consider
the piece of land Surplus to
requirements
so if we
accept that we do feel this is open
space
then the nppf has very clear
um requirements it prevents development
on public open space unless
one of these three Clauses is satisfied
sorry okay
so the first one part a
um the local planning Authority don't
believe it's Surplus to requirements
because as part of their application the
parish council did not submit an
assessment demonstrating this and the
objections we've received have
highlighted
the various users the residents wants it
for
so part C isn't really relevant because
they're not suggesting to build Sports
recreational facilities so that leaves
it up to members to debate
are they go are they meeting the
requirements of Part B
so
the loss that's occurring as a result of
this proposed development is it being
replaced by an equivalent or better
provision in a suitable location
and it's Part B
that the LPA believe hasn't been met
the site is shown in pink
if this was removed
um I should say perhaps before that as
part of our application
the parish council have stated that
they have acquired an additional six
acres of land adjacent to the Blackburn
Community Center so they believe that
this meets part B of paragraph 99 by
providing a suitable alternative
however
that is not tied to this application the
loss that results from this development
is
not going to be
um
mitigated by the provision of this
additional land this additional land has
already been secured and that's already
going ahead so it's not tied to this
application
in terms of its suitability
the one of the main usages for that site
marketing pink is a more informal play
space for much younger residents where
parents are quite happy to say yes you
can meet with your friends on that space
very close to our house
if the other option is walking along the
yellow Pathways marked up on the screen
above
to the Blackboard Community Center I
question whether parents would be quite
so happy
the route involves walking up to the
main road with heavy hgv Vehicles
crossing over the railway line
and then going down the footpaths north
of the Railway line some of which look
rather enclosed and the alley-like going
between
residents backyards
therefore we don't believe that
the provision of this six acres at
Blackburn
is an equivalent or better to the type
of facility being provided by the flat
grass area within the estate at the
moment
so this is an area closer close-up of
the site in question
if we move on from debating whether
paragraph 99 has been satisfied
and just look at the site in context
this aerial shock clearly demonstrates
that the plot is of a similar size to
the adjacent property to the west of it
and so therefore it's considered a
reasonable
that you could fit a
dwelling on the detached dwelling on it
this indicative plan also shows that
um
it would be reasonable to suggest that
you would have a similar parking area at
the front of the property in a similar
sized rear Garden is the neighboring
property labeled as number 10 up on the
screen
this is the plan showing the visibility
space displays we've consulted with
Suffolk County Council highways they
have no objections on highways grounds
for the highway safety
although there were a couple of
objections raised to the proposal on
highways grounds the nppf makes it very
clear that you can only refuse planning
applications
if there is an unacceptable impact on
highway safety or the residual
cumulative impacts would be so severe
and the traffic generated by one new
dwelling is not considered to have
severe enough impact
and I should add that the visibility
splays marked out on the drawing do meet
um
the requirements by Suffolk County
Council of 59 meters in both directions
the road is speed limited to 30 miles an
hour so it's
steady traffic
however looking at the site even if
members felt that paragraph 99
requirements had been met we have a very
major concern that we don't believe
could be overlooked
overcome sorry at Reserve matters stage
and that's the residential amenity and
the lack of privacy
because you've got these four properties
on the side
numbers two to eight of crown Mill
they are perpendicular to the plot and
whichever way you try and orientate the
house you will end up with those four
properties overlooking their private
patio space immediately to the rear of
the property
and just because it's an infill site it
doesn't mean that you should have a
lesser standard of an amenity is
acceptable
generally we would say you need a
greater degree of privacy than is being
offered by this site
if we return
to the nppg which talks about open space
and the definition the highlighted areas
are quite important
it also talks about open space being an
important part of the landscape and
setting of a built-in environment
the spaces Within
the development
also form part of the pattern of the
development and form part of the
character of the development
and amenity is something that makes life
more comfortable and enjoyable
and having a well-spaced out development
does enhance your well-being
the loss of this open space We Believe
is
um
would be have a demonstrable impact on
the character of the area
and we believe it is important to retain
it it was part of the original design
and it was designed in for a purpose so
that it didn't turn elmswell into a more
urban environment that it did actually
reflect the fact that it was a village
within a Countryside setting
so bringing that to conclusion
the
we feel that the site should be
considered public open space as that was
marked on the reserve matters
as such paragraph 99
has very clear requirements to allow
development on those sites which we
don't believe have been met by this
submission
even if they meet the requirements of
paragraph 99 we don't believe the
overlooking concern could be overcome
having said that the plot size is
acceptable and Consultants don't object
on a Highway's safety ground or on
environmental grounds with regards to
noise from the railway
so we recommend to refuse it thank you
I'm sure we've got I've got a question
and I'm sure as well as well um can I
just ask so
it's an open piece of land that looks as
if it was uh brought forward when the
houses around it were built it kind of
looks it was deliberately left there
because there's a sign there so was it
just is that there's no management
company anymore
it's that piece of land is all that's
left and it was obviously gifted to the
parish council to maintain both both
pieces of the land highlighted in blue
on the plan marked as public open space
were handed over to elmsworth Parish
Council in May 1999.
to be maintained in perpetuity thank you
councilor
um chair if I may I've got a question
for the legal officer and then I've got
two questions for the officer because
I'm just a bit concerned that
um mid-suffolk's cabinet made a decision
on Monday to potentially build 50 houses
on a large area of open space in
elsewhere and that this Council has made
you know obviously I'm not on the
cabinet but the cabinet has made a
decision to progress with development on
a very large area of open space and and
that's been
um agreed to progress and that here
we're now so I'm just worried that we're
hence I know Phil's looking at me but
I'm I'm worried that
you know they've made there's no
consistency we've made one we the
Council made one decision on Monday and
now we're you know I'm just want to know
where I stand if you if you
if you thank you if I start an ink
correct me when I go wrong
um you the cabinet decision is nothing
to do with planning so the rules in the
nppf are completely distinct there is as
I understand it's some pre-application
advice to be gained you can see in
paragraph 99 what the requirements of
the policy are the question of
consistency of treatment would require
those policy tests to be met for that
development as this so in terms of
consistency what cabinet do is
for cabinet if I'm honest
having a decision is does not that
decision does not impact the decision
this committee has to make today because
we're only making a decision what's
before us today
yeah thanks for that I just want to be
clear because I think that decision was
only made two days ago and here we are
discussing open space in elmsworld again
so I just for the avoidance of doubt I
think we just need to be
clear about that
if I can come back in German I mean for
the avoidance of doubt we are highly
aligned to the issue of paragraph 99 as
officers and you know we would expect to
advise that that will have to be dealt
with as part of the planning process of
considering whether that site is
suitable development notwithstanding
whatever cabinet
no it's fine thank you
um like two questions for the officer
thanks Helen for that is um in 10.2 of
the report it refers to
um that the crown will development
Incorporated grass undeveloped gaps
I'm assuming the gaps there's only two
gaps I.E the crown Mill play area that's
on it's next to the um Railway Crossing
and this site here if you could just
confirm that and secondly I understood
that the this bit of land was or that
area originally was to do with getting a
crossing over the railway line
and that's why I was left but can you
just confirm that thank you
um so yes the originally elmsworth
Parish Council requested that this piece
of grass was left so that they had the
option of putting a Footbridge from
there across the railway to the northern
half of elmswell they did
um
they did apply three times and get
permission for said Footbridge but it
hasn't been built out
um
although
that was their original intention when
the reserve matters was granted it was
clearly marked as public open space
and um
presumably I mean I I wasn't here in
1994 but presumably that was also to
protect the LPA that it would be
maintained as public open space if the
Footbridge couldn't go ahead it wasn't
just because they only wanted the public
Footbridge there so yeah so just to be
clear it wasn't it wasn't designed as a
public open space so when it was when it
was first built it wasn't built as
public open space it's just become
public space when the Railway Bridge
hasn't gone ahead
when it was approved at the reserved
matter stage it was marked as public
open space
sorry chairman if I can just enter it so
this side are we saying that this site
was marked as public open space
so if you go back with a slide that's
got the two blue areas
in 1994 although that was why elmside
Parish Council requested it when I read
through all the history of the site that
was their intention for it
but it
and in some of the documents it makes
reference to
the parish council's surprise that it
was marked as public open space and not
just marked as space for a Footbridge
but it was approved as a public open
space
okay that's clear thank you oops
the questions
nope okay so we'll move on oh you've got
a question before we come on to you yeah
uh yeah I do have a question
um what do you actually have a record of
the distance between the first floor
front windows of uh two to eight Carmel
to the edge of the plot
scaled
called it
you can mount
you measure off the plan essentially
yeah so when the plans are submitted I
measured that as approximately 10 meters
so 10 meters from the first floor
Windows if you can take me back to the
slide that shows the photograph of the
houses
huh
so about 10 meters from those properties
to the edge of the site
okay so we'll move on
so now the parish council would normally
speak then an objective then a supporter
than the applicant but we only have the
parish council here who are the
applicant so you are actually speaking
to the applicant rather than the parish
council but over to you and you have
three minutes please thank you chair uh
I was personally involved some 30 years
ago
in some fairly Lively negotiations with
a developer which resulted in their
agreeing to Omit one of their housing
plots on Crown Mill
to leave space for the landing of a
Footbridge next to the Revlon
subsequent negotiations with the
landowner on the other side of the line
and with the railway Authority were
equally vigorous but less productive and
it was not until five years later that
the first planning application was made
for the Footbridge
was refused but successfully appealed
the inspector's ruling in allowing the
appeal confirmed that the open space on
the south side of the Railway line was
retained to facilitate a future
Footbridge and he referred to condition
16 of the permission for the estate
the inspector also considered that a
functional Bridge of simple design would
not be out of keeping in this location
whilst working towards making their
scheme a reality the parish council
secured two successive plenty of
permissions for The Village's Footbridge
despite opposition from immediate
neighbors who sought instead
to have a two-story dwelling on the site
the intervening years have made a
functional Bridge of a simple design
untenable as regulation has required
more and more complexity in the
engineered structure and it's become
clear that the site is no longer big
enough to fulfill its purpose
and it is Surplus to requirements it was
never thought of or rescheduled as a
public open space
meanwhile I confirmed that as mentioned
by the case officer in your papers the
parish council originally acquired the
railway Tavern site from Green King at
the Arthur village with outline
permission for eight large dwellings and
has set up a community interest company
to refurbish and manage the pub together
with elmsl Community Land Trust to
develop up to 12 affordable community
homes in place of the eight Market units
the affordable scheme is currently being
pursued in partnership with the
registered provider and the parish
council has formally resolved to
transfer the benefit which might accrue
from the development of this Footbridge
site towards The Village's Community
Land Trust initiative
the timing of this application
uh
took account of the recent acquisition
of a further six acres of recreation and
informal play Space at Blackburn which
must be seen we suggest as more than
adequately addressing the paragraph 9
mppf constraint
the 17 Acres of blackburne facilities
are a few minutes walk from Crown Mill
along footpaths and separated from
traffic
there was and is adequate provision made
for green Recreation space on the crown
Mill development including the
children's play area with a minutes walk
from anywhere on the estate
the case officer confirms that the
elevation and layout of The Proposal are
suitable and this is to be expected
given that the site was originally
intended as a building plot fitting into
this state pattern your time is up to
your last sentence please we suggest
there's no statutory or policy reason
for refusing and we ask members to weigh
any reservations they may have as we
continue to innovate towards providing a
broad base of benefits for our community
very much
don't worry
okay
um so we'll now move on to the ward any
questions sorry any questions first of
all for the parish council
no okay so we'll move on to the ward
members we have two however you want to
play it
yeah sure
uh thank you uh I'm somewhat surprised
that our officers are recommending this
application for refusal given that it is
within the settlement boundary of the
village and none of the statutory
consultees are objecting they may have
suggested condition conditions but
they're not objecting
as we've heard before when the crumble
and Crabtree Meadow development was
first mooted this plot of land was to be
another house and it was only after the
parish council intervened uh that it
became clear of buildings because of the
uh proposal for a Footbridge over the
railway line
the fort Bridge gained planning
permission in 2004 and which was
subsequently renewed in 2013. so since
the RN permission the reserve matters
permission which identified this as
public open space since then it has
become the Footbridge site and that is
what is known as within the village it's
always been known as the Footbridge site
um and as we've heard from the parish
council that Footbridge is now unlikely
to be forthcoming
this piece of open space is is really of
benefit to the residents of a small
proportion of elmsworld the residents of
crown Miller Crabtree Meadow
it's not of that much interest or use to
the majority of the elmswell residents
I'm not sure that prior to covid and
Jubilee Street parties that it was much
more than an informal piece of grass
used by the immediate neighbors the
other piece of much larger public open
space between Crown Mill and Station
Road adjacent to the railway line was
originally to be the only piece of
public open space within that
development and it is well used by a
number of residents from all over the
village the player area is often used by
children on their way to and from school
but I haven't seen that many people
using this particular rectangle of grass
understandably there will be a loss of
biodiversity but this is much less
significant than other many larger
developments within the village
we've got six houses on Ashfield road
which were in a piece of privately owned
public open space adjacent and not
public a privately owned open space
adjacent to a public footpath they have
been approved and are now almost built
out these six houses are outside the
settlement boundary there is no public
footpath uh safe public access to the
middle of the village they are cited on
an ancient open common of button our
green which has which has historical
significance these houses fill in gaps
of open Countryside and up will be
include include much more significant
loss of biodiversity
this application is within the
settlement boundary and is not on part
of an ancient common so that's why I
find the officer recommendation for
refusal somewhat inconsistent
the officer report also suggests that
there might be some overlooking issue
but is this any more overlooking than
you'd have in any Housing Development
the spacing of the dwellings opposite
this site
is similar to elsewhere within the crown
Mill and Crabtree Meadow development
after all this site was in the original
configuration of the Cranwell and
Crabtree Meadow estate as a dwelling
um so the separation looks similar to
that which is over the road in Crabtree
Meadow
elmswell has suffered with several large
developments and will grow by over 40
percent giving rise to private financial
gain here we have a public body needing
to raise some Capital without further
increasing the parish precept with this
proposal I realize that Finance is not a
planning matter but I would rather
support the public purse the national
house building companies
the parish council are committed to
several exciting projects in the village
namely a community housing project on
the land adjacent to the tavern
they're planning to utilize ground
Source Community heating for both the
pub and the affordable housing and this
requires capital investment this is the
benefit which outweighs the harm caused
by this particular development
thank you sure
um I instinctively don't like to see
another house built on a plot that's
currently Green Space
and do we even need this house arguably
not as you'll all know we have a
National Housing Surplus at a good local
housing land Supply but of course we
also have a housing crisis it's
expensive and it's difficult to save for
a deposit while living in privately
rented housing and of course the key to
this is far more social rented houses
lower rents let people keep more of the
money that they earn it lets the
taxpayer save on benefits so elmsall
Parish Council has earmarked the money
that this land this piece of land would
fetch on the open market with planning
permission to help develop a group of 12
affordable homes which will stay in a
community Land Trust in perpetuity so
alongside Parish Council are joining
mid-suffolk District Council in trying
to solve the housing crisis for the
benefit of their residents
so maybe this single house is needed
after all but do the benefits outweigh
the loss of the Green Space
now as the report points out planning
policies H3 and sb2 allow development of
infill sites within settlement
boundaries unless it's desirable to
retain a site as an important immunity
or open space within the village
paragraph 3.14 of the committee papers
says that this plot is a visually and
functionally important public open space
and that's led to the first reason for
refusal an intrinsically important
amenity space but it's really as you've
seen it's a tiny scrap of land in this
surrounding housing estate landscape
it's really little more than an extra
wide Verge along the driveways of the
houses opposite another house here would
fit in quite well and it would as others
have said have good easy pedestrian
access to the center of the village and
the other green spaces that are very
close now that second reason for Refuge
reason for refusal the private immunity
space of Hose dwelling would be
overlooked by first floor windows and
neighboring properties well the the back
Garden would be no less private than any
others 10 to 20 Crown Mill are already
overlooked by their neighbors any house
that's close to another will be
overlooked terraced houses and anything
set within about 10 meters of another
house are permanently overlooked until
at least until the gardens mature if
you're going to go with that reason you
have to refuse nearly every application
you get including all the ones that I've
sat through this morning
so the common sense reason why you
should Grant permission is that it's one
small plot in a large housing estate
with green space close by and the grant
of permission will allow enormous
knock-on benefits to the entire Village
and arguably to to the whole country
questions for the ward members
nope okay so after us discuss debate and
come to a conclusion
Council Mathis yeah I think it would be
appropriate if I spoke first to
reminding people that I did declare at
the beginning of the meeting that at the
relevant time in the late 1990s I was a
member of the parish council so I can
confirm
um very much of what Mr Dowd said on
behalf of the parish on this application
I just wanted to first take people's
just very speedily through the history
it's unfortunately the history tends to
get printed in the wrong order but I'm
really sorry
if you're going to give us the history
then I feel you're acting you're you're
sort of going outside the grounds of
this committee yeah we've already heard
no representation we've already had the
history presented is it new history is
it anything contrary to what he's been
told it's just to understand it's a
country to what we've been told no well
then I don't think we need to run
through this yeah we'll keep out from it
right so it it helped it helped me to
sort
of
so
I think the the key Point really is that
it it wasn't intended to be and is it
needed as public open space now I I
would suggest that the reason it was
it was it was marked in 1990
um or late night I think 1999 or maybe
94 when the plans were written in 99 it
was transferred to the parish
um was because there wasn't any other
sensible designation but the
if we we I don't think we need to
particularly treat it as a needed public
open space as you've heard it was going
to have a house on it originally and
um so I I haven't got a strong view
about whether we should say yes or no to
this but I just want people to
understand what happened at the time and
that the intention was quite clear to
try and get the Footbridge put there and
that's why that piece of land was not
developed
so
just with that thought in mind I
everybody else have a
custom answer sorry I'm really sorry
even you meant um thank you chair
um I'm a bit bemused by this application
because I mean I know the area well and
um I just feel different things have
been highlighted in the report but not
not the most recent application which
was for a Footbridge to
for the railway and you know there's a
lovely park at the in Crown Mill at the
state
um that's you know one minute from these
houses that's got an area of play area
and it's got an area that's um
sort of not got trees and things so it's
kind of a nice area that you could
gather on sort of thing and
I I just you know I wouldn't
you know this this is a bit of open
space it's a bit of leftover I don't
think I would classify it as important
as much as I love bits of Green Space
everywhere and it's not that there were
there are other bits like this in that
um development I mean that the the
report says gaps but there aren't any
gaps there is the pla the play area and
park that was originally designed as
such and there was this one little gap
which we've heard was going to be a
dwelling and then it's and then it
wasn't and it was going to be for the
Footbridge so
I'm minded just to you know go against
the officer recommendation and I would
be minded to propose approval of this
because you know I think the things that
they're doing in elmsworld are fantastic
that the parish council is currently
um working on and I think for the sake
of one house that would have originally
been there if they'd have gone to the
original outline permission back in
whenever it was there would be a house
there anyway so I'm I'm like I say I'm a
bit bemused by it but
um I appreciate people wanting open
space outside their doors or a green
outside their doors but
um I would want I think we should be
approving it thank you chair
formerly proposed uh
to to refuse the officer's
recommendation
that's a double negative
vote for approval okay
okay
um I've got a question if I may
we talked in the previous application
that there had to be 35 meters was the
distance uh between I think it was the
block of flats and the other side of the
roundabout here we've got
um I think it's a 10 meters does that
can you just clarify what what
implications that has yeah would you
mind if I came back on the atmospace as
well chair is that yeah super just want
to say with the open space appreciate
all of the planning history it
nonetheless is open space we've got
evidence that it is used as such so we
need to assess it through paragraph 99
so we might need to just run through
members thoughts on that if we might
just go with an alternative options
um in terms of the sort of overlooking
and
back to back or back to front distances
you're normally looking at yeah 35
meters would be potentially back to back
so your private space onto your private
space how do they look down upon each
other's
private space
similarly yep if you've got houses next
to each other the way they look is we'll
say an angle so the bit closer to your
house back to your patio where you can
sit and have a barbecue is more private
and the view down there is limited you'd
have to peer straight out of the window
so the general view is more private what
we're saying here is these houses are
quite close and they're going to look
straight down across all of that land I
think you see it quite easily the
photograph that land will be well viewed
by people in those houses from the first
floors and you've also got the parking
the anything that goes on out the front
of those houses would have an impact on
the back Garden it would be more noisy
and more affected because of that
relationship so it's that combination of
things in this case that is of the
concern for us I've got one more
question
um uh before we come back to debate is
um the impact we've heard about this
land you know the
the house being built to build another
proposition which obviously is a very
worthy cause but is that something that
we have to consider as part of the
planning application
in terms of paragraph 99 to
what we were looking at I'm just looking
at here is Part B so the the loss
resulting from the proposed development
would be replaced by equivalent or
better provision in terms of quantity
and quality in a suitable location so
that would
would be do members feel that this piece
of open space is being replaced by
um
an equivalent or better quality and
quantity
it's not something they've brought
already that's something that would have
to be in the future so the six acres of
Woodland that's just been bought doesn't
count
is that what you're saying I think
that's what we're saying earlier yes
Mr pudding
so
can you hear can I be heard the
u4 I think you all know well that
there's no in general terms no legal
duties give reasons for a grant and a
decision to give planning permission but
where you're disagreeing with an
officer's recommendation is often wise
to do so Council Eben is clearly your in
Broad terms indicated why she disagrees
with the officer's recommendation but we
if we follow up what Gemma says with
that when we when the resolution is
framed
okay well I mean I'm happy to speak if
no one else wants to know I mean I would
take a differing view to counselor eburn
because to me it's a it it it may feel
nonsensical and I totally understand
what the parish council is saying but it
is a open space that is designated as an
open space
uh and it's in the heart of a community
and it's been like that for many many
many years now I think the project
you're doing is brilliant so my question
would be how do you overturn an open
space to make it viable and that isn't
what's been presented to us to me today
so I totally accept what the pressure
Council was do I can see why you want to
do it it makes sense but we've got an
open space that's been an open space for
30 40 years uh is used by the community
is well used and doesn't meet the test
under bullet point B to me but obviously
it's up for discussion
yeah
uh happy to keep going around the room
but then obviously we're still looking
for a second for County Burns proposal
so councilor
um I think my main concern with this is
basically what was mentioned in the
previous report that you should have 35
meters and I can see those those houses
at 2468 looking over more so they've got
less privacy and they're losing
obviously some of their immunity value
because of that
um so personally I I would actually
agree with the officer's decision to
refuse this application I think it has
been used as open space for a number of
a long time we've got a certified
petition against it
um okay this there is a park allegedly
uh just down the road about a minute to
walk away but the local restaurants
there like this is open space I I think
it's reasonable to keep its open space
and therefore I personally agree with
the office decision on this one thank
you
yes uh it is public open space
it would be very interesting to go back
and look at the original design
documents with this development
were the houses just opposite the public
space
everything else is very linear
were those four houses put on that
configuration because there was going to
be open space in front of it well that
could be the case and that would be
supported by the visibility issues that
we've been discussing
it was there for a Footbridge
but I see as being a huge bonus for the
community to have this
um if I were living in that Community it
would add value
yeah I
I certainly can't second the proposal
and um
see value in the space care if I may ask
us I can see the way it's going I'll
withdraw my proposal because
um I haven't got a second there and I
can see the the line of um
no no no I'm going to withdraw it
because I I do need to leave the
meetings very soon anyway so
thing before we go on to the next person
no did you want to propose it based on
what you've just said
do you want to propose repeated proposed
um acceptance of the officers okay John
over to you and we're looking for a
secondary to that
proposal yes
so I found the office's arguments pretty
logical and and well constructed and I
don't always agree with everything I
hear from Health resistors so that was a
a pleasant feeling
I recognize as we're saying that the
parish council clearly has plans and
clearly has a need to raise cash and and
yes it is quite probable that this area
well it's this was
destined to be a house but I think the
point of the orientation of the the four
next trip where were they uh arranged in
that order
when it was known that this this would
be handed over as open space with the
intention of putting a landing place for
a bridge there or not
certainly the they are very close and
overlooking is always a problem and 10
meters is very short
and I have as I'm sure we all have a
number of emails from residents
pointing to the value of this as an open
space
and if I can remember back to when my
young children it is pretty convenient
to have an area which is
hoping to surveillance as this is from a
number of houses and which you can allow
quite young children to play essentially
unsupervised and develop
develop their confidence of you not
constantly having a parent within 10
feet of them
so I find the salt that this is a useful
open space has been used as an open
space quite compelling and the thought
that the overlooking is unacceptable
equally quite compelling
so I was happy to sign that
happy to second that okay thank you so
we've got to propose in a second that
does anyone else wish to speak before we
go to a vote Council Matheson yeah I I
think you you'll um
chair you did say nonsensical
um and yeah I
I do feel that was actually right and
you you know you then went on to go with
the with the strict planning situation
um that that it is designated as a
public open space Etc
um I'm I'm I'm not in support of the
officer's recommendation
um I did just want to ask Gemma is it
some any significance in the fact there
were two parallel applications both
granted on the same day for the same
piece of land here that's it seems a
little curious and I know that's got any
relevance to um the wording seems to be
identical but presumably there were two
different versions for a reason
um and um yeah I I
I do feel on the hull that I would like
to approve rather than refuse so we've
got to propose in a second just before
we go to the vote Philip you wanted to
come in did you thank you chairman yes
just just very simply
I think if the parish council set out
what their equivalent or better
provisioning quantity and quality
arising from this development not that
they were doing anyway one would be you
know you'll be well placed to consider
this but in terms of governance
paragraph 99 is a very real requirement
within the mppf it's not just about open
public open space it's about open space
generally you know and it has always
been a good principle to you know to
protect space between buildings in
locations such as this
so that reasoning that committee has
Lord although the aims the parish
council has for the money from this do
need to address paragraph 99 and I think
that would be a very constructive way
forward for this
okay
yeah I think there's a bit of a timing
issue really that the the parish
councils as for decades had an
aspiration to go beyond the Blackberry
I'm really sorry that's not relevant
until tomorrow John they got lucky and
got the land before they got the this
application that also makes it sound as
if you've predetermined your decision no
no
so I'm really sorry please you
so we will now go to a votes
chair members
members progress
bought or against the officer
recommendation of refusal
a vote four would be a vote of refusal
against the application and a vote
against will be vote to approve on the
application
okay
um for my modern God has disappeared
thank you thank you chair
all right
thank you members chair that's six votes
sorry four votes four and two against so
that is refused okay thank you thank you
very much do we have any slice
inspection requests that needed to be
reported as committee
okay good so we closed the meeting at uh
3 25. thanks everyone for joining us
today